Now recording to server.
We're now playing girl talk all day.
All Day bitches.
Oh,
watch it till resume is just,
hey,
this is the rag.
It was just a temp way.
Him plays my eight hits at the side just to hold the Gucci Bucket with the flap
on the agenda though,
Nigga.
This ain't no go on pal.
I'm starting to slaughter.
I heat,
my shit goes to all to end all deaf to satisfy my people lived and
what today is and let us put,
Angela said,
no doubt.
We don't speak in a blink.
Compose can have good sleep and in the clinic and only cause they begin on the
seat is the Nigga be id.
I trying probably people in the club and Tom to cut a rug.
I'm double
double visiting people in the club.
It's under Coteau Bro.
We can't hold us up in this guy.
Just thought.
Does
it make you can grab a club stop.
I'm just playing.
Go talk to all my plays in the back.
Sipping,
Yak.
Is this the same dude?
Yeah.
This is a mash up a bunch of songs by girl talk and who's the,
who's the wrapper that was,
you know,
I have no idea.
Damn,
that guy's good.
Yeah,
it has really good.
He's original too.
Like the way flows.
It's original.
I tell you girl talk.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a guy that matches songs and if you go to his website,
it's been hammered since he released this yesterday,
but he just released a new CD and the best thing about girl talk where I trying
to find a lot of my music from it's,
I'll listen to that and he'll match mash so much music.
And I like a part of a song.
I'm like,
all right,
who song the original part of this song?
Find out who that is.
New,
new,
new artists.
I like.
So girl talk is great for finding out about new bands.
This is a weird time for music,
man.
They can just get famous by getting online and having cool people find out about
it and they tell other cool people and it spreads through email.
So much shit get,
there's just so many bands,
man.
It's impossible to follow them all right now.
Yup.
It's the fucking Internet bitches sticking over flashlight.
That's Brian.
That's him doing his professional duties to alert me that we're supposed to say
that we are sponsored by the flashlight and uh,
it's uh,
uh,
masturbation tool,
implement.
We've talked about it a million times.
I don't think there's any other ways to describe it.
Uh,
I support the product.
It's effective.
It's,
uh,
it's quite embarrassing if you cry it using it,
but whatever,
man,
you gotta get over that Shit.
I have successfully trick to people and to putting their finger in my used
fleshlight in the last week.
That's not a trick,
man.
You ain't Lance Burton motherfucker.
You just an asshole.
But I did it live.
It's a trick.
I did it live on.
Why would you do that man?
Because they just test my dick.
You know how everyone's pulling out their dicks and putting on your,
you know,
at like all the comics,
Hey,
look at my dick.
Oh Hey,
you know,
all that stuff.
I found a way around it.
That's even worse.
You're touching my dick and come to what is wrong with you?
Why would you want anyone to do that?
Yeah,
that's like a salt.
You can go to jail for whatever you do.
You could ruin a person's night and ruin their sleep.
Ruined their performance at work.
It could lead to them getting fired.
They get fired.
Their wife is a lot of pressure in the house.
She gets divorced,
their kids grow up.
Fucked up.
Why?
Because you decided one day on a critical night to make this guide,
touch your use fleshlight and he's fucking steaming all night fucking poured.
They go home and finger their girlfriends and wives and I get them pregnant and
I start knocking up bitches left and right.
Wow.
Could you imagine if that was possible?
Just stop and think for a second.
I mean,
I know that's a ridiculous notion,
but what would that be?
The saddest fucking way to get po?
Did you hear about that one woman that got pregnant?
She blew a guy and she got stabbed.
Okay.
And somehow or another in the knife wound,
the fucking sperm got into her uterus and fertilized her egg.
That is the or her ovaries.
Right.
What kind of wherever,
wherever the eggs are positioning kid,
is that going to turn into a mansion that well,
the,
the crazy thing is I think there was something nutty.
Like she was born with no vagina.
It was like the whole thing was a freak show.
It was in Africa and I think I might be making this up.
I think she was born with,
no,
I remember this.
I was born with no vagina and she just run around.
I just guess given Dude's head,
the poor young thing,
it sounds like the birth of a comic book heroes,
he was born in Africa to a woman would know vagina from a gash in her over at
the bottom.
Is that the most like no one can talk shit.
If you're from that situation when you're at school,
you know you could,
you know,
kids can be like,
my dad's a cop,
you know,
and the guys would be like,
my dad is a fireman and he be like,
I don't,
no one knows.
She was just sucking dicks and some loads survived and someone stabbed her.
She shouldn't even have a vagina.
There was no exit for that.
Learn God.
What a fucking shitty roll the dice.
If you really believe in Karma and you really believe that you are the product
of your past lives and who you are and what you,
what you learned in those lives and it's carrying over.
And that's why I know not everyone is equal.
What the fuck did that guy do?
Well,
no,
and also like who is this vaginalis,
blowjob port girl.
Exactly.
The poor girl.
What a shit roll the dice man who is,
you know,
who is that girl?
What was she in another life?
Yeah,
I know.
It's like it,
it,
that's one of the big questions is because if you do believe in Karma,
then you have to like,
it's almost like people use that as a way to like not,
not accept the universe as being like a really brutal place.
I get mad when people pretend that they think they know how this thing works.
You know,
someone was trying to talk to me about Karma and he was talking to me about how
he doesn't worry about crime ever.
I go,
why?
He goes,
because I just feel like if you don't put that out there,
it doesn't come back at you.
I go,
that's ridiculous.
babies and bys explain it.
All right.
The baby putting that out there,
is that what's going on?
The babies putting that out there and the baby gets shot.
Listen motherfucker,
this random shit that goes down.
Okay.
This,
just because you might have control over your immediate environment most of the
time doesn't mean it's not,
you know,
the world's chaos man,
he can't tell me,
you know,
and it's like why the secret was so offensive to a lot of people.
You know what all that was going on.
Like you're telling me that all diseases and everything that people will,
those on themselves really for real.
Okay.
So much.
Someone wills having a foot grown out of the fucking head so people will,
you know,
twins that are stuck together at the brain and share one skull.
You know,
come on man.
It's such a weak thing because it kind of,
the end result of that is it's like,
so when I'm at the beach and I'm walking down the beach and I turn and look at
the miserable woman pushing her baby,
who's obviously like severely mentally retarded in that baby's got tubes in its
mouth and it's like [inaudible] like I'm supposed to look at that kid and think
you're getting yours.
You getting what you deserve from the universe because in a past life,
yeah.
What the fuck?
It's ridiculous.
Empathy and compassion for that kid.
You can kind of be like,
no,
he,
he deserved that.
Yes.
There there's,
there appears to be a lot of randomness,
man.
There's a lot of randomness.
It's,
I mean you,
you can't put your finger on it either way.
I mean,
we might be wrong.
It might really be that simple.
It might really be that person did something incredibly fucked up in another
life.
I mean,
we don't really know,
but it just doesn't seem like that's a nice way to think.
No,
and I think it's awesome.
Kind of a real,
you know how like people who say if you talk to someone is like I don't believe
in God.
And then you ask them what their definition of God is.
Then quite often the god they don't believe in,
you shouldn't believe in because it's like the guy with the beard and the
whatever and the Toga.
But if you,
but for people who,
when they do the same thing as reincarnation,
so it's like they turn it into this like thing where you are an animal or a
person or whatever.
There's so many,
the thing we talked about once about reincarnation and that's only one,
one version of it.
There can be a million different versions of how the energy that your
consciousness is travels through the universe.
You know?
It doesn't have to be through reincarnation or through through the normal sense.
Maybe you come from an alternate dimension before this one,
someone completely different place.
Something where it's like octopuses floating around in some ether that can
communicate telepathically.
Maybe that's what you came from.
Why does it have to be from Earth or this planet?
I just it,
well,
I'll tell you one of the weirdest things about,
uh,
the biggest DMT experience that I ever had was when I,
when I did it,
when I,
when it first,
when it first popped over to the other side,
I said I've been here before.
It was like a very clear feeling that I've been there before.
So the idea is like maybe there's like a little waiting room,
a waiting room for the universe.
That's like everything all connected and then every now and then you just get
stuck into some sort of a situation,
some confined existence or you're working your way through this world,
trying
to make sense of it,
you know?
And then you'll end this one and pop out into the main lobby area and the
waiting room.
And let's see what happens next time.
Something totally fucking completely alien and different beyond your
imagination.
You know,
the confines of our imagination is based to what we've experienced.
our,
our whole collective idea,
what the world is,
is based on what we've experienced.
Even photographs and things that we,
you know,
haven't experienced but can see,
like things that are in the galaxy and planets and shit.
I mean we used these and we have this,
this whole map of our universe,
but that's just what we see right now.
There is just,
it's only limited by our ability to think outside what we've already seen.
The universe could be infinitely fucking bizarrely complicated to the point
where every different dimension has its own laws and rules and every different
universe exists in the center of every single black hole like that.
That might be all real shit.
I could might be self fucking infinite and crazy and we maybe can't see it.
Well we shouldn't be able to see it cause it's so big.
There's no way where these little tiny little bits of of neurology down here on
this ball and we're supposed to be able to,
there's no way we could,
we could reckon with infinity,
with the our limited minds.
It's weird that it's like a,
it's a statement that if you you,
if you talk about it,
people go,
oh yeah man,
space ma'am,
but you want to talk about space,
man wouldn't,
shouldn't we be thinking about the,
what am I doing?
I'm piloting this fucking flesh vehicle around this,
this,
this.
There's some sort of a dimension filled with other flesh vehicles.
If I didn't know what this was,
if I came from,
no,
no judgment whatsoever.
It just a total neutral point and I looked at just human behavior moving around
on the planet.
I want to be like,
this is the most psychedelic shit ever,
but just us.
We were like the craziest character in a fucking movie.
When we landed into La the other day,
we flew in from Germany.
We got in a metal tube.
We flew from one side of the fucking planet where it was 10 hours ahead in time.
We flew all the way back to la,
landed on the same day to these lights and shit and all these other metal tubes
are flying in from everywhere.
And I'm like,
we are in the future or at this.
This is some crazy fucking science fiction shit.
It's going on right now.
We don't even realize it.
This whole world is psychedelic.
Yeah,
it really is,
man.
It is.
It's fucking crazy.
The craziest things of when you've come across flowers or nature,
you look at it and you're like,
all right,
this is a fucking crazy.
If I had this thing painted in my living room,
I would like have a panic attack and die.
You know,
it's like the most amazing thing you could ever see ever.
Or it's also funny that everyone on this planet are,
many people on this planet think they're living their own individual lives and
they're completely free.
But then when you go and look at the interstate and you look at the way people
like,
we'll move through the city.
You see,
it's just this like bloodstream of like stop,
go right,
left,
stop,
go right
left.
And they're all there.
Every single person,
when you look at cars inside that car,
they're going to see their girlfriend or going to their mom just died or they're
going to,
well,
they're all having these amazingly complex experiences and they all think
they're the most important fucking thing.
And yet even in the midst of that,
they're all operating exactly according to this bizarre technological pulsation.
Stop,
go left.
It's like flying at night.
It looks like a circuit board and you looked like,
you know,
just the light's going through surgeries and stuff and it looks exactly like
beyond the mind's eye to,
it really is.
I mean,
the world is fractal.
You know,
we talked about when you were talking about flowers and gorgeous flowers,
flowers and like beautiful pine cones and shit.
They all follow the FIBONACCI sequence.
You know,
it's a mathematical sequence that is like literally the order of the Earth,
right?
That's the golden mean,
I believe is what they call that.
I don't know what it is.
I don't understand math.
I'm a math retard.
But this Fibonacci sequence they use to describe all these fractals,
beautiful fractals in nature,
like,
like pine cones and like certain flowers and trees.
And it's like,
just like,
it's a part of the structure of,
of,
of everything.
It's like literally like,
I mean if you look at what it is,
it's like there's a code like,
oh my God,
there's a code to this world.
And then what's the code to that?
What's the code to each individual part of,
you know,
the,
what's the code to the pine cone?
What's the code to the tree?
What's the code of the planet?
It's eventually going to come down to we're going to have the code to
everything.
We're going to stand,
understand everything and we're going to be able to recreate it.
You know,
I read this thing that Ray Kurzweil said,
um,
about how,
and I,
it was really fucking intense.
He said that,
um,
matter itself is like code.
Like in the computer,
your computer right now is projecting a US or whatever and it's coming via some
sort of code in the same way.
Like at the atomic level,
everything's just a code.
And once computers if accelerated to a certain rate,
they will be able to send nanobots out that we'll deconstruct Adams and
reassemble reality in the same way computers deconstruct and reassemble pixels
and um,
video and that sort of thing.
So matter in reality itself will become,
it's just like a,
I don't know what the word for it is a um,
uh,
just a raw material that you can use to construct things.
All you have to do is get like a hydrogen atom and a whatever Adam and another
item we just don't have,
well we don't have nanobots and even if we did,
we don't have an advanced enough computer that could run the swarm in that way
to do that sort of thing.
You know what I think the next thing is going to be,
or one of the next things is going to be,
it's going to be the ability to print things in your house that isn't paper to
make things out of nothing.
I think you're going to have machines at a certain point in time that are going
to be able to actually create something like Ipod,
right?
Like if you order an iPod and you turn your machine on and this is going to be
the shit like,
look,
we're gonna make an iPod right now and it's going to be a huge novelty.
Just like the VHS tape was the VHS tape.
Like Holy Shit,
we could record TV shows.
Nobody ever thought you could stop it,
take a leak,
come back and watch
it.
You remember what a pimp you were when you first recorded your first TV show on
a VCR with a clock.
You use the clock and you came home and there was a tape waiting for you and
you're like,
I'm a fucking genius wizard.
I'm living in the fucking future.
Dude.
That was a big deal.
Oh,
I remember when my friend got an answering machine to create.
That was a crazy deal,
right?
What's going to be crazy?
That's how they will,
they'll start selling things like they'll have bigger ones for bigger things
like,
oh I want a car and stuff,
but then you're going to get the,
the hackers have it.
They're like,
what do you want?
It went 10 Camaro's right now.
Tin Camaro's should imagine if we can just,
we have the just unhindered ability to just start printing shit and making fans.
That's the possibility.
That's going to be what time travel is somehow,
well,
you know,
maybe get printed dimensional travel,
do a changing of what Matt matter is.
If he could just recreate matter.
I mean you have to have something to recreate it with though,
right?
You'd have to have raw materials that you would put into a printer.
You would have to have,
I mean if you're,
if you're constructing reality,
you're just building,
that'd be dolphin or something.
It's going to be like we have to use bunny rabbits.
Just wrap your head around that.
Could you imagine?
You would have to have like a certain amount of minerals and a certain amount of
like carbon and all these different things in your house and somehow or another
you would turn on this machine and we'll just bang print up this TV for you
unless you could print the fuel for it.
You know,
like if it's some kind of mineral,
it got so good.
You a real pimp.
You would have like a room,
like a big room,
like a garage where you just printed shit all the time.
Yeah.
My print me up a Jaguar.
Check this shit out.
Fuck that.
I'm printing up some ecstasy.
I met a cat.
I meant the actual cat.
I didn't mean a car that was saying it while I was saying I was like,
what a poor choice of cat because it's a shitty car.
That could be a bad miss on a shitty caution.
That's a bad jaguar.
Jaguars actually looked pretty dope.
Now.
I like how you have grasshoppers in here.
That's cool.
I'll keep it like homeboy has been with me for a day.
No,
that's cool.
It's like a little pet for you.
Well,
I'm going to let them out eventually,
but I don't want to freak them out.
I want to go home and get comfortable.
He was all locked up for awhile.
Now it looks like he's moving.
Have you fed them?
You should feed them.
What am I going to feed him?
I don't even know what day he leaves.
I think they have to eat the leaves of the,
you don't have to eat specific.
Yeah.
I think when bugs start eating leaves,
that's what they eat.
You know?
If the one type,
that's what the,
hmm.
I think it might be just making that shit up.
You know what I missed?
They don't have out here is those furry caterpillars.
Do you remember the ones that they looked like little mustaches,
those things rule.
I know what they do have out here a lot though.
Praying mantises when I see a lot of those bad mother fuckers to a premiere
mantises are like,
if they were big we'd be fucked.
It's just that they're small.
That's it and we think it's cute.
I have.
There's a picture online of a praying mantis is so big that it jacked a
hummingbird.
Why so I,
Oh yeah,
I saw the video of that dude up fucking hummingbird.
Could you imagine this hummingbird is cause they stand like super still and they
blend in with the twigs and this hump.
This fucker was so big.
This is hummingbird.
Got clothes like I'll fucking giant alien monster from,
what's that movie star?
Quite alien was the movie with the kids and the fucking,
what was it?
Goddammit.
But the one with the big bugs and shit.
Science fiction movies.
Very handsome man.
Denise Richards,
spaceship troopers or whatever.
Remember those big giant as bugs.
Yeah.
That's,
that's fucking praying.
Mantises man,
they're just small.
I heard that new movie.
What fallen or something like that is the most cheesiest like next movie that
you watched as a comedy are skylights guideline.
Yeah,
I heard it.
It's so bad.
Even beats that Dennis Quaid one or hurts really bad too.
I want you to go see it.
Why can't people make it?
Why can't people make a good side?
Fine.
As long as I know it's bad.
I'm good.
What?
I get upset with a bad movies when I don't know.
It's bad.
When I think it's going to be good then I go home.
You mother fuckers look like paranormal activity.
I got mad at paranormal activity two I collect you can get at first.
Yeah.
But there was um,
a girl in it.
It looks like a certain ex girlfriend of yours or she added like 40 pounds.
Who,
which one can't tell you.
I can't tell you
what.
Anyway,
she told me
dog Brian
in your dog.
Duncan had a,
an awesome dog party at his new house the other day.
And uh,
once you explain what happened,
so,
um,
a lot of my friends were there with their dogs and other dogs are having fun and
bright.
What kind of dog do you have Brian?
He can ease.
Brian has this Pekinese dog looks like that dragon from the never ending story.
It's,
it looks exactly like that.
That's awesome.
Sackler courts.
This is adorable dog.
And we look over and uh,
my friend's dog is like humping it and you know,
whatever that happens at a dog party,
no big deal.
It's like,
you know,
I've stopped,
what are you doing?
That dog goes back and like,
you know,
as being really insistent.
So it's turning into the whole dog rape thing and it's like digging it's fucking
things in.
Yeah,
that did it.
Like just
fucking a fucking his dog.
Not freaking out at all.
Relaxed.
Kind of looking over a boy or girl.
Okay,
so anything fixed.
Yeah,
but so she kind of thought it was like massages or something.
No,
she's a whore.
Your dog's a fucking whore.
Whoa.
Listen,
every fucking dog at that party started fucking his dog.
I've never seen anything like it.
They were fucking face and her,
they were fucking both sides.
Handoffs were fucking my time.
Dogs were standing in line.
I've never seen Doug stand in line.
There's a line of dogs humping,
fates,
humping background.
The two girl dogs to guard.
He's just screaming and heart.
God started taking the dogs away and my dog and look like it was like wet and
like pre cum all over the place.
Like it just looked like it was wet dog collars,
dog party turned into this orgy,
this weird gross amateur porn.
Okay.
Oh,
your dog or the no self man.
She was,
she didn't,
I don't think anyone successfully got their Dick in her denial,
but they were,
all the dogs were freaking out.
Like what?
Really with a tragedy.
Denial.
This is the first stage,
but there was,
there was a lot of air hampers that just like circled around.
The outside happens after they come to grips with it.
That's stage two.
I thought it was acceptance,
anger,
denial,
anger to acceptance.
Going to get mad that your dogs that tramps.
I made a Twitter profile of it now,
so it's a,
it's like a tramp Twitter dog.
This is Dee from the Geto boys says you got to let a hobby.
Oh
Wow.
It can be out there,
captain.
Save a hoe.
Don't do it.
I ain't worth it.
It was really weird.
There was like your dog puffed out some pheromone and we did look like she
sprayed stuff probably like dick bro.
That's what it is.
You know you don't give enough attention.
You fuck.
Wow.
If you were maybe pet in her a little bit more.
I just wouldn't be out there trying to get dick all over the place.
He was proud of myself though.
I didn't want to stop it.
I was like,
no,
she,
she deserves it.
She's been a good dog.
You're proud.
And I was like letting her have some ingrates raping and dangling.
It didn't go from everyone trying to stop their dogs to everyone being like
fascinating.
Who Was it?
The party is a bunch of comments,
a bunch of comics and
imagine that you were a bunch of squares.
The one fade them comes with his dog and he goes,
you know,
my dog has never humped anything in the road.
You don't have to worry about my dog.
My dog went right to it cause it possible.
This is impossible.
I've never seen this happen.
I've had this dog for 15 years.
He's just like,
I can't believe the bitches,
this submissive.
Let me just check my Dick Right in your face real quick.
No talking.
Just face mounting.
There's certain girls that give you the green light for that.
There's certain girls there that crazy.
Twix.
He vixen is one of those puppies.
Well,
no,
we do want to talk about the name of this dog.
No,
no.
Okay.
Let's not talk about that.
See vixen.
It makes my heart hurt.
Hurts my heart.
I heard them are,
it's just a character on Twitter,
but she had done it,
but my puppy now has an Amazon wishlist,
so if anyone wants to buy,
I'll do it.
Don't you do it right line or a Mac book.
Pros know you wonder why your dogs or whore.
You're raising a whore and nicely.
A little whore dog.
Amazon wishlist letter half dog toy whore dog.
Fuck that shit.
You have been an unexpected thing.
When Amazon had been at the wishlist,
they did not know that would turn it in.
By the way though,
that made it sound like I was not in support of girls using the Amazon wishlist
with is,
which is absolutely not true.
I am 100% in support of that shit really cause and for women you have to say it
but you also have to say it for math,
you got to let a whole be a Ho.
Right.
There's some guy who wants to go out and buy this chick TVs and new shoes and
underwear.
I fucking,
I go get that money girl.
Yeah,
no there's no problem with it.
But the problem is is some of these people on Twitter are saying things like,
hey,
you know you
should give me something here because I showed you this and I did this.
You know what?
A lot of them are like really pimping it out.
Kind of gross to do.
You don't have to give them anything.
Oh I know.
I know 80 it's would give them in a night.
It's okay.
No,
I'm not against it by them shit and give them money.
Look Dude,
ever known.
Then what I do,
I'll,
I'll follow,
like if someone says something and,
uh,
like,
like a,
like a porn star.
Like I follow a bunch of porn stars.
So they say some fascinating shit.
And uh,
every now and then like a dude will say something to them and they'll,
they'll our 10 and I go,
Ooh,
but that was fucking creepy.
You know,
like,
you know,
blah,
blah is the most amazing person ever.
And so beautiful.
My God,
our t o thank you,
lol.
And I'll go,
okay,
who's this crazy ass hole?
So I'll go to this crazy assholes page and it'll be like he's having a
relationship with her.
He's talking about how ever since she's been in communication with him,
he just feels so much better and his life is more,
more meaningful and it feels like he has a reason to go on and he feels like
she's an angel and she sent to this call room zee.
Shit,
loneliness is so disgusting,
lonely.
Like when you get that lonely,
where you've gotten nuts and you can wake up in the morning and,
and really feel normal about having a relationship with an online porn star and
no one wants to hang out with you and no one wants to talk to you and we saved
up enough money and you're like,
today I'm going to buy a bottle of obsession.
When I think is crazy as the road of Warcraft couples where they just play
together all day and all night and that's their whole life.
They've never met,
ever hung out with each other,
but they're dating and they play video games,
get married,
they get married inside the video games.
And then,
I mean we've discussed video games to death,
but it is,
that is a fascinating thing.
This desire to exist in this,
this two dimensional online world instead of the three d reality.
And it's a weird pull,
you know,
it's a weird pull to want to.
I mean,
look,
I'm guilty of being online all the time.
Like a lot of times,
even when I'm supposed to get work done,
I'm such a Douche bag that I'll just turn on my computer and then I'll check
Twitter real quick.
How is this crazy winning?
Somebody sent me some crazy science video and I look at that and I go,
wow,
they're fucking,
they found a new black hole.
Oh Shit.
And then it's two hours later and not have even started writing.
Why?
It's just,
she just get sucked into it,
man.
How can't you though?
I mean it's like you,
you tried to get off.
You're like,
oh,
Beatles on iTunes.
I can shit on them for saying,
you know,
why they into the world of Warcraft?
Why am I into my message board?
Why am I in the,
you know,
uh,
going online and reading a cool document or watching cool documentaries and
reading weird fucking s studies that they found.
It's a fucking,
to me,
it's a drug.
I got it almost like I was at badly addicted to world of Warcraft.
Yeah,
we talked about that.
You,
you had,
um,
he would break the Games.
So just so you can't play him.
I would.
Yeah,
I would fucking,
well then,
I mean I had already gotten over my quick thing when you were getting this
right.
It was,
I mean the draw,
the pull,
it's amazing.
Fucking game is so powerful.
I finally,
um,
I had a level 70
warlock and I had to fucking delete the character.
Why didn't you sell it?
That's what everyone says you should have sold it.
But it's like how much is that worth and geek world?
I don't know.
You get your Dick sucked for that.
Yeah.
There's some crazy golf bitch.
So it's sucky level 70.
[inaudible] what do you,
what is,
what exactly was your title again?
You were a,
what?
It's called a warlock with warlock level 70 level 70 huge.
There's like you could just fuck people over I think,
but I think that the levels are up higher now.
But back then,
I mean I was definitely fun.
Now if a chick bought this character after she sucked your Dick,
if she sucked your Dick and got this character,
what happens then?
Does she get to be a warlock?
Cause she would get to be a dude.
Can anybody be whatever sex you want.
I don't know where it is.
And I think you want,
you can change the way it looks,
but I don't know if you can change the gender.
So she will be your character.
She'll take over your character.
You give her like the passwords.
Yes.
Yeah.
And,
and yeah,
you would give her all the password and all of a sudden she would be infinitely
powerful without having earned it.
You probably have to do with the transfer of ownership,
like go to a game stop and both signed papers or if that's how you do it.
I know you do like that.
Oh my God,
there has to be some kind of transfer of ownership because then that person
would just say,
this is my character know.
Let me ask you this.
Do they allow that shit?
They'll,
they allow people to do this.
I don't think you're supposed to do,
but why didn't you get prepared before you got on this podcast?
I can't believe I'm kinda happy.
I don't remember this.
Why?
Why do you think they would prevent that?
I've wondered that.
I think it's fair.
I mean,
it's just another fascinating aspect of it.
I guess maybe it could be because they would say that they should get the money
if somebody got the money.
But I feel,
I feel like if a character invest all that time into the game and they can,
they can show something for it and they could sell that.
That's something that's just going to make the game more popular.
I knew somebody who is a,
what do you call it,
I can't remember what they call them now,
that people in the police of the game that are kind of inside the game
in the game,
they have characters and they can,
they go around,
they can appear and do shit.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and they're indestructible but they're kind of like policing the player,
like moderators medicine,
a message board moderators this the same thing.
And they,
I actually,
before I played world of Warcraft,
God,
this is,
I guess it's,
I'm,
I'm fucking neck geek.
I'm a nerd.
I,
before I got addicted to world of Warcraft,
I got addicted to a everquest.
I got busted.
I got busted in that game by like a game cop,
like I cause like at the time it was still kind of like the wild west and they
hadn't liked really figured out how to like regulate it as much as they have
now.
And so,
I don't know how it is in everquest now,
but then you could like try on other people's stuff.
They could give you stuff and you could try it on.
And it was like,
I,
um,
uh,
there was a guy who had a really,
everyone knew in this game about some kind of like very powerful vest.
And so I went to that guy and I'm like,
Hey,
let me try that vest on to see how I look in it.
And he gives me the vest and I just run into the woods.
I go race,
go racing into the woods.
I've got this little care,
a little character,
uh,
halfway named hair pie.
His name was thereby,
and I'm racing into the woods with this thing and like the guys like yelling
into the zone is what it's called,
like announcing don't trust hair pie.
He stole my vest of the thunder guys thief and I'm running,
I'm wanting to words,
I've,
I lost him.
Oh.
And all of a sudden I hear footsteps behind me like invisible footsteps and I'm
running and I'm hearing like this and then I'm frozen.
It's a game.
Moderator,
he's like,
you gotta give him his vest back.
You can't steal vest.
I'm like,
you can't steal like that.
my character is a thief.
Why not?
And he's like,
read rule four 98.
And the tos a thief,
you should be a fee.
You should be able to do whatever you want.
I know what I mean.
That's what I can't steal as a thief.
That's why grand theft auto so good.
If you want to be a murderer,
you can be a murderer.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean you're,
you like,
you hear about it from time to time.
I just heard about,
um,
somebody who claiming that some of their shit got stolen on that.
I can't remember the name of the game.
Second life.
There's a whole economy in second life or people don't.
People pay,
people pay rent to have shops there and stuff.
I know,
but then fuck.
But the moment they figured out how to,
right now it's just such a primitive version of it.
Like,
do you remember when you first got an Atari,
did you ever get an Atari?
Yeah,
shittiest gaming system of all time.
But you felt like you were on like in Star Trek when you were playing that
fucking thing,
like look,
breakout.
Remember breakout that venture with the key,
the dragons and the key.
I've been having so many holy shit that was only x amount of years ago.
More.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Boom.
So now just think,
okay,
what is the next version of this stuff going to be?
If you look at what a tare has turned into and it's obviously it's gotta be
neurological implant,
it's gotta be plugging in or transmitting somehow and yeah,
I think it's going to be holograms,
man.
Because did you see that Japanese star that they have now?
The singing star.
That's actually a hologram.
What sells out fucking,
oh my God,
I tweeted it the other day.
It's amazing.
You have to check it out.
We have to find it.
Brian,
is there a way you could pull it up put,
because this is something you guys have to see to believe.
It is a sold out.
Brian's going to look for it on the Japanese Hologram rock star.
Look up that dude.
It's crazy.
It's an animated fucking character that singing in a computer voice and it's a
Hologram that they have on,
on stage in front of fucking thousands of people and the place is sold out and
they're going insane.
They're screaming and yelling and cheering for this hologram.
I mean,
it's like,
it's a super advanced version of like the opening at a ride at Disney.
Wow.
But dude,
it's a beautiful
hologram.
I mean,
it's like three dimensional intense.
The way it looks is incredible.
It's like really vivid.
The colors of vivid.
It doesn't look that opaque or that transparent.
Rather
look at the fucking crowd.
Folks.
If you want to go over this,
Brian,
would you,
what is the Google Japanese Hologram?
Pop Star,
Japanese Hologram.
Pop Star motherfucker.
This is what the new gorillas,
uh,
concerts are supposedly going to be in line.
They're going to do that too.
Where it's walking through the audience though.
Like this,
that's the new,
I think next week here in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's incentive.
We can eat some mushrooms.
Good a girl.
Oh my God.
I'm scared.
I just got terrified.
Like a little curl.
That's fucking bad for folks.
If you haven't seen this,
if you just seen your car,
you've got to go home.
You gotta check this out.
It's one of the weirdest things I've seen in years.
Weird man.
It's an electronic voice too.
I mean,
people were complaining that the backstreet boys were fake.
Who did you meet with the fuck?
This isn't even a real boy.
Imagine this.
If this chick was naked,
yeah.
Oh,
she's going to be sucking big giant octopus.
Dick's starts this clicking through it.
There's going to be for sure some version of that in Japan where they have just
Hentai rape and Samurai swords and shit.
She Shooting Eagles out of her book.
It's all going to happen.
No doubt about it.
The Japanese don't give a fuck walk.
That is awesome.
I could look this all so advanced.
She was hot.
You know,
they look at our computer like if we have our cell phones around there and if
you go over to Japan,
our cell phones are goofy.
Their,
their,
their cell phones.
They can buy shit with them.
Right.
They go to a store and they just run their cell phone by something.
I can pick it up.
They're like scan it and they just buy it and walk out with it.
It's incredible.
They can buy soda with it and Shit and plane tickets scanned their,
their,
their phones or school scanners.
It's ridiculous.
It's fuck man.
I'm pretty amazed at that.
Yeah.
Gorilla supposedly,
uh,
they're making their next CD.
They just announced that it's going to be there making their whole CD on the
IPAD.
Could you imagine just 30 40 years ago,
how about when Elvis was on stage?
How about one of these fucking appears out of nowhere and is dancing around
right next to Elvis.
People would start shooting it,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean just just back then it would've been like,
what the fuck is that
man?
We don't even realize how quick this is all happening.
No,
I mean,
no,
I think that nobody's really prepared for it.
And the quicker it happens,
the more I used to be like burning it,
let it happen.
Let the fucking singularity pop.
Let's go.
Let's do the thing now it's kind of like shit.
I don't know.
Like I'm cool right here.
Life is so easy.
I'm a comic,
I'm having fun and we don't need to accelerate that much.
Let's not get crazy everybody.
I'm having a good time.
We don't have to,
we don't have to Zap and is to have
to all be one.
Yeah,
we don't have to emerge.
Come on man.
But you know,
I guess there's just no way to stop it.
And so I was flying back from Germany and I had this crazy epiphany about
civilizations cause I was,
you know,
I was leaving Germany.
I was like,
it's so strange when you go to another culture,
you know,
and you're,
you,
you don't have any idea what they're saying.
It's like,
God,
this is a different world is totally alien.
There's songs that they had on their,
on their,
uh,
their TV shows.
We're,
we're all in German.
They have played a lot of American music though.
I got a say like a good percentage of it.
Like every now and then you'd hear something with a German voice or a German
German dialogue,
but for the most part the lyrics.
But for the most part it was all American shit.
But the,
the people would talk to you,
they'd look at you and butch notes,
lactic and you're like,
Whoa,
like I don't have a fucking clue.
I don't know.
I just,
I have no idea.
And they would look at you like,
come on,
come on.
Come on.
Like at the airport when they were telling you to go over here,
what they're saying,
whatever.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Nick mystic,
no clean.
And you're like,
what,
where,
where it's,
it's a fucking strange thing man.
And I'm,
I'm thinking about how bizarre it is that there's so many different languages
and I'm thinking about how weird it is that some of these cultures had been
around forever.
And,
um,
and then I start thinking like,
what the fuck happens to all these different cultures that have existed before?
It pretty much is the same thing.
They figure out how to create shelters.
Then they go from having shelters to creating a surplus to having a group of
shelters.
They all protect themselves from the animals and then once enough to worry about
getting eaten,
then they start figuring things out.
Then they started inventing things and coming up with things,
getting curious to the point where they make a very complicated society that
hums along.
They have a May immense structures and all these cool things and then all the
people that did all this crazy hard work have kids and the kids are born into
this perfect world where they don't have to try to,
to,
to discover anything.
They don't have to create things because the things are already existing.
They don't have to develop a civilization and a scratch and figure out how to be
strong in the woods because there's all these resources.
They figured out how to write things down so they don't have to relearn shit.
And I'm like,
wow,
it's just people get soft.
Like that's probably the reason that every single civilization eventually fell
apart.
You know,
he talked about like,
you know,
throughout history,
whenever they would talk about like the fall of the Roman empire.
Yeah.
Tha Tha tha tha the whole theme to it was always the decadence and the depravity
and the crazy sexual shit that they were doing and how life had just gotten in
sand for them.
They were all like living in,
in eating insane amounts of food and fucking little boys and having people fight
animals and shit.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's got to have come from a place where those people were weak.
Those people didn't have to put it all together.
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
I think specifically with the Roman Empire,
and I'm sure people out there will correct me on this belt warrant,
wasn't Rome sacked by the Visigoths who are these like brutal barbarians.
You just came in and just raped and killed everybody and Natalie.
Yeah.
And that brought in the dark ages and I'm the dark ages.
What was bringing a civilization back out of the dark ages was um,
uh,
Christianity,
religion,
religion was like creating at least a little bit of order to a kind of like
bring people out of the dark.
But all of a sudden the vikings figured out that all they had to do is go to
like a monastery or a church and they could just grab all the gold and shit and
go off.
They basically,
the vikings discovered Europe and they started,
they came in and pushed it back into the dark ages again cause they were sacking
everything.
And like vikings are the most brutal fucking,
they were the most brutal humans ever because like that,
one of the stories they told us there was a viking who had this funny nickname
and I can't remember nickname,
but the other vikings laughed at him.
They thought he was funny because he wouldn't kill kids.
They thought it was funny and they had a nickname for him.
Like you pussy,
you are he killing these kids?
It's fucking fun.
And they would just go in and kids and there were these crazy Rudel fucking
warriors.
And so,
like you said,
you're dealing with this kind of,
well,
at that time it was starving people,
but before that it's these lazy fat,
uh,
people who've never really fought before,
at least like fought in that brutal level.
And they just got,
they just kind of hit at the wrong time.
Yeah,
exactly.
Had gotten hit back when Rome was strong and before everything fell apart,
they probably would've been able to hold those guns off the idea.
Yeah.
And I think,
yeah,
I think,
I think that is the idea that,
I mean,
I don't know anything about the history other than the what's connected to it in
popular myth.
So always gluttony and orgies of food and you know,
the talk of feathers in the throat vomitorium so they would throw up so they
could eat more.
Yeah.
Well that's the,
I mean that,
that usually is what happens is people,
I mean really that isn't that a symptom of people confusing what's important
with the material universe.
Cause people start trying to gratify their centers.
And,
and really that's just a distraction from what's really important.
And the,
so when that gets to the extreme where everyone is just focused on buying shit
or floats,
I think it's a faulty system that we have.
And once the environment gets super complicated,
it's eventually everyone's gonna want to take time off.
They're going to want to not have to hunt and gather and they're going to want
things easier and lighter and they had to want more for their kids.
I don't want my kids who struggle like me.
And so then we want a softer,
easier world development.
But the problem with that is w Schumann's ideas and our,
our,
our best inventions have come through hard work and adversity.
People who like people who have worked very,
very hard to think things through and figure things out and invent new things.
Well,
when everything's already there and you don't have to do that,
like what happens then?
And then you have kids and they see you and then we'll look at this lazy fat
motherfucker.
Why should I do anything hard or try to be anything special or try to contribute
or try to figure things out or even try to be happy.
Nobody else has happened.
What the fuck makes me think that I should be happy?
Well,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
I really think that it's a result of people losing track of,
um,
the greater truth in the universe.
And so I think the moment you start tuning into that,
that's when you start getting the ideas that lead to the inventions and lead to
the hard work.
Because fucking hard work.
Like,
you know,
everyone says if you want to write a book,
you gotta write six hours a day.
You have to treat it like a job.
You have to fucking write all the fucking time.
And that's true.
But you know,
to really do that,
you've got to be passionate.
You've got to want to do it.
You have to be inspired.
The inspiration drives you to work that hard.
And so right now,
no one's inspired.
Most people have no inspiration cause they're not connecting to the thing that
brings those big ideas into your head.
When maybe that maybe when there isn't the Internet and technology and all that
stuff,
it's more likely that those ideas come to you or something like that.
I think it's also possibly a situation where the hardware has evolved so quickly
that our life has changed so radically that are our physical bodies just are not
in tuned to the reward systems that we're getting from this society.
That's why we're trying to supplement them with antidepressants and shed.
Our bodies are designed for some hunting and gathering and fucking,
that's what our bodies are designed for and if you don't exert a certain amount
of energy,
that's why people get stressed.
You know that people who exercise are way more stress free than people who never
exercise because your body just accumulates all this crazy shit that you're
supposed to be getting out of your system.
You're supposed to be chasing down elk and shit.
You're supposed to be moving bails of Hay and if you're not doing all that stuff
and you're like,
why do you even have Mussel beds?
You just sit around the house and jerk off.
Why do you even have,
you should have enough muscle to get to the refrigerator and back to the couch.
There also,
you don't need any other muscle.
It also seems like there's a lot more calculations and math going on too,
because if you think about even 15 years ago,
you're not thinking about Twitter numbers.
You're not thinking about Facebook numbers are thinking about online stuff and
bills and and news and you have so much information pump that your brain is
constantly thinking way more than it was.
Then back in the day was like,
oh,
it's windy outside.
That was,
Ooh,
this eliminate.
It's good.
I wonder if someone who could buy us beer,
right,
but you know that we are different.
Is that what you're talking about?
The numbers.
You're talking about red band,
these are all illusions.
People are spending all their time calculating these filaments.
Thrill idea,
my bank account number,
how much I owe or how much data you says those Zeros are aware what the fuck
type they're imaginary or the Senate or the Congress or the president or the
government,
all imaginary things that aren't,
they're just these a theory things out there when it's like if you go into your
backyard and dig and plant seeds and grow something that's real,
you can look out there and see how many seeds or plants you have growing up and
that.
That's fucking real.
What is the economy?
Just imaginary quantitative easing and we're going to buy stock shares and stock
trades and send them over to brush men,
Boston,
Ben Bernanke,
he said he's going to double the quantity.
It's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Land was completely free though,
would be more of the case.
Now you,
if you don't,
if you know pay bills and live at someplace you,
you get kicked off land and there's no free land.
That's how it all started.
Is the native Indians being like,
you want it?
You want to buy this land with the fuck he talking?
Yeah,
seven bucks.
You could have Manhattan,
Indiana,
than any other mother fucker like you dumb mother fucker will get to the idea to
them was absolutely,
completely ridiculous.
And now the whole thing is criss crossed.
All of society is crisscrossed with tiny,
weird connections.
The deed to the house and the land and the house and the certificate of
ownership of the House and the property tax you pay and all this,
it's all imaginary shit.
None of it's real.
We all believe it's real.
Now only do believe we believe her.
It's real.
But we're so focused on it that we've forgotten about what Israel,
which is the material universe,
which is the fucking,
uh,
water and the ground and the environment.
And we're just pumping shit out into it because that stuff doesn't seem real.
It's a leisure thing.
You go out for a hike in the woods on a Sunday,
that's when you go into nature.
You maybe on occasion take the lady for a picnic,
you know,
but that's how you go to nature.
And now,
you know,
and it's just a,
it's like a novelty.
Well look a tree,
that tree dude,
nobody realized how more than me when I actually moved to the woods when I was
living in Colorado for those months,
three,
almost four months.
And uh,
when I was living,
I was basically living on a dirt road on the mountain,
like in the middle of nowhere,
like literally completely in the middle of nowhere.
And you see everything that you see all this shit that's alive.
It's just running around out there and man it out here.
I see a deer every now and then out here.
I mean,
you know,
you see like,
um,
uh,
coyotes all the time and every now and then someone will see a mountain lion in
this area here,
but in Colorado was all over the place.
It was like you were in there,
their area,
like they walked through town,
there was this place called evergreen and every year the elk would migrate
through town and you're talking about hundreds of these giant animals.
They're like deer on steroids.
He's big fucking Brock Lesnar looking deer and they walk into the middle of
town,
they don't give a fuck.
They walk right on the the streets.
Hundreds of them.
Dude.
It's insane.
Like this giant migration of them.
It's amazing.
And you know what goes with them.
Lions.
All right.
Mine's follow them.
So when they come around,
you've got to worry about mountain lions being around to the fact that oh yeah,
noise that used to be life.
One Dude shot one in his backyard while I was living there.
It uh,
it gotten into his chicken coop and was jacking his chickens.
Imagine that fucking terrifying moment where you go outside and there was a
monster eating your chickens in a cage and it quad its way into this cage and
it's in there now and you've got to shoot it before it eats you.
Right?
Cause it could eat you.
It could say,
Whoa,
this is way better than a chicken.
Let me just eat this old person.
Yeah,
that's real.
Yeah.
If you don't get good with that finger,
motherfucker,
you got to get good with that finger.
You better have an aim bitch.
Well,
like our version of that is I got a parking ticket.
It's the same,
it's like
a negative force impacting your life,
but it's a much more humbling and beautiful forest that makes you appreciate
your real place in the circle.
You know,
when I was living up there,
what I really loved about it is that I would go to New York and shit and I was
like,
when I first started moving there,
when I first moved there,
I did the open Anthony Show and uh,
I stayed in this hotel in New York that had this crazy view and I looked out the
window and I'm just like,
how weird is this that I'm like right now I'm on the death star and I live with
fucking grizzly Adams up in the woods.
That's where I'm living right now.
Like this is a,
this is my,
my new place.
So I'm going from like the wilderness to cities and we'll invest to La a couple
of times to wilderness to different places where I did stand up and I was like,
this is one of the fucking strangest ways to look at things ever.
Because now I'm getting at you.
I'm like,
I'm looking at the whole world from the outside.
I live on dirt,
I live on dirt with trees.
That's all that's around you.
And when you like that and you're in this like really tight little small
community up there because very,
very few people,
you get a totally different view of the whole world.
It's all going on in Saudi Arabia,
you know in Iraq.
There's issues right now with bombs and shit's blowing up and they're starting
the,
the uh,
the fucking,
the,
the Mecca there.
They're all making their pilgrimage to Mecca and all this is all gone.
The news and I'll just look out and I'll still a little chipmunks and shit.
Shit much were just chilling.
Chipmunks don't give a fuck about Iraq and Afghanistan.
It's doing near here.
Don't like,
what are you tripping on dude?
Just relax.
Chipmunks.
People are trying to eat us and we're cool.
Yeah,
that's,
we'll see.
And so that,
that's what,
that's an experience with something called health.
That's what,
that's what it feels like to be healthy if feels like it's,
it feels like to be,
we are so connected.
I think with our physical hardware,
our bodies that are set up for the caveman days,
we're so connected with what our bodies need that if we're like completely
plugged into the system,
I think our whole shit is getting rewired like in this weird like super quick
way because we have to keep up with all the bullshit you have to be aware of in
life and you don't have this peaceful time that people used to have.
Like even when people were hunters and gatherers and shit,
when when they will fucking made houses and they figured out how to make fire
places and shit at the end of the night after they killed an animal and the
sitting around eating it,
they were fucking relaxed.
You know what I'm saying?
And let them owe anybody shit unless they're stressing about things that we
didn't stress about.
Oh,
there's a blizzard and our house and it's way better to be alive now.
I'm not saying that there's definitely right about that guy.
There's an anarchist that you can look up and his name is John Zerzan and he's,
it's a fascinating guy.
He's very intelligent.
And he talks about his premises.
Actually,
no,
uh,
that was times were terrible.
But before that and the distant past,
before people started using language or assemble systems to represent reality,
we were in paradise.
I don't buy that man.
That's so speculative.
And,
and what the problem I have with that is if we were in paradise,
why did it all turned to shit?
I think have this romantic way of looking at the past.
And I guarantee you,
if you fucking go to the zoo and see how do she,
chimps are to each other,
you know,
watch documentaries about chimps sneaking across lines and beating the fuck out
of other chimps and killing them.
And then coming back to their little,
look,
man,
I'm not buying it.
We evolved because of competition.
That's for the most part,
the only reason why things get better.
They get better because I have to,
because everything else is getting better around them.
So if we were in paradise,
why the fuck are we come up with language and fucking,
I agree with you.
I don't agree with Zeros.
And I was just knocked out.
Their brains get infinitely more complex as things go along.
It's just going to happen.
It's the,
the ethic of the universe.
But that doesn't mean that at one point in time when it wasn't as complex,
it was better that golden age that's there.
They're crazy.
They're all kinda talks about that a little bit though.
He's his,
his psychedelically induced though,
which is much more plausible theory.
The idea,
his idea is that Mckenna thought that at one point in time the monkeys had gone
and the,
the climate had changed and the rain forest had receded to grasslands.
So the monkeys were climbing out of the trees and experimenting with different
food sources.
And one of them was they would flip over cow patties to find bugs down date and
the,
yeah,
and they ate mushrooms and they developed and,
and,
but that one is based on like an actual plant that exists.
You know what I mean?
And so like an actual time where the,
the,
you know,
rain forest did receive,
this is all fact,
that's all science.
And they know that much monkeys have eaten mushrooms.
Man,
they know a bunch of different instances of all sorts of animals eating all
sorts of things that affect their consciousness.
Like elephants will get used to like fermented fruit and they get drunk off of
that.
It happens with monkeys if they get,
they get used to booze.
Somebody posted on my Facebook,
a great video of Orangutans,
David Attenborough,
shelling orangutans,
washing socks in a river.
One of them is trying to saw a piece of wood.
One of them's got a hammer and it's hitting a nail,
kind of looks like in dawn of the dead when the zombies tried to do shit.
You know,
like they're kind of doing it wrong,
but they're definitely like Zombie.
They're imitating,
you know,
and it's,
it's like look it up,
David Attenborough orangutan.
I'm sure it's there,
but it's like you look at that and you see how quickly the orangutans are
adopting these sort of behavior patterns from what they're watching and you can
see how quickly it would all fucking happen.
I,
it's just a trick.
And they're all trained monkeys and that is,
and they're like,
all right,
now you're going to be hammering here,
right?
Yeah.
Actually that's what the first thing he said is,
these are not trained monkeys.
These,
they're just imitating.
How do you know Brian?
And I said,
maybe he's a liar.
He's not a liar.
It's the whole thing is fascinating,
man.
I think the idea of evolution happening right before our eyes is fascinating.
Yeah.
There was a lizard that was fucking,
forget the exact story,
but it's very clear evolution and the change of its,
its stomach because it was on an island for 20 years.
I mean they came from one environment,
they had to adapt to a new one,
but they adapted like super quick and they're still there alive with like a very
clear difference between the lizards.
So to come from,
you know,
the original origin or original source,
you know what I mean?
The Congo is another perfect of that.
You know,
the Congo,
like 2000 years ago,
the Congo was grasslands and it be,
the climate shifted very quickly in all these like prairie or plains animals.
Like,
I'm like gazelles and a even rhinos,
they're stuck in this rain forest.
It just kind of grew up around them.
Weird Dude,
the Congo,
we've talked about this before on the documentary and I don't know how to get
this.
The documentary is from the BBC.
Um,
and it's not available on DVD.
I tried to find it.
I can't fucking find it.
Might be,
isn't that illegal?
We would never do that.
Brian.
You do that?
I own it.
I own it on VHS.
But VHS is just so God damn clunky.
Not only do I want it on Vhs,
I own it on VHS.
That's an English version of VHS.
You know what I'm saying?
Like isn't there an English version or is that just DVDs?
No TV.
No,
there's a VCRs work or,
yeah.
What is it?
All region.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So I,
it's,
I only have the English version.
This,
I have a fucking,
I bought a VCR specifically,
so I could watch this documentary.
Like I wanted to make sure that I go watch this documentary.
So my VCR plays American shit and it plays.
But this fucking documentaries insane.
Man.
You realize like this whole ecosystem to change in 2000 and right,
right.
Fish in the Congo climb out of the fucking water and walk on the ground until
another pond and he jumps in the water and then he gets eaten by this crazy bird
called the shoe bill.
Holy Fuck.
It's,
you wouldn't even believe this God damn thing was real if you didn't see it.
It's six feet tall,
like five,
six feet tall,
giant ass fucking bird with our huge beak.
These big fucking burdening bone crushing beak.
That's what it is.
And it's just this,
this fish that's trying to walk from one place to another jumped into the water
and this Burgess Jack's,
it just a murderous crushing fucking jaw and he's evil eyes.
Man.
Birds have some of the nastiest,
most evil fucking eyes they do.
Dude,
if they hadn't fucking media didn't hit 65 million years ago,
we would have been fucked.
We will never become us,
would never become us,
have never figured out how to kill all those lizards.
There's lizards,
didn't die,
brother.
They went underground.
Mckenna fucked my dog.
Reptilian reptilian transformation.
Have you seen the reptilian transformation videos on the Internet?
They were so funny.
Proof that,
what's his name?
Who's that crazy guy does interviews,
lyric dike proof that Larry King is a rep telling you and it always has this
dramatic music playing kind of techno music.
This is like,
hmm.
And it slowed down on Larry King and for whatever dumb reason,
Larry King licks his lips like,
and it kind of looks like a lizard,
but right when he licks his lips and music changes and it's like,
dude,
like this is a proof that fucking Larry King is a lizard.
Sure isn't a joke.
No.
Oh,
people believe in the reptilians table.
Doesn't that sound like a tiller or
it's just the ongoing troll on the Internet that you're falling for?
No Way.
It'd be Brian.
That could be,
there's a lot of trolls.
There are so many Goddamn trolls.
So many people that think it's funny to pretend to be somebody who they're not.
Oh,
I know a little bit about that.
But I think that the,
the,
the uh,
these are serious.
And I,
I told you the time I talked to Eddie Griffin.
He explained the whole reptilian brain at all,
even my credit card number.
Why do you think he's just making it up as human beings on the planet?
How long would the dinosaurs on the planet look how much we evolve and the time
we were here?
How much more did the dinosaurs evolved?
He would hit you with some shit like this.
Who'd like to take a drink of his like little champagne bottle?
He's doubled his little Paul Mooney champagne bottles.
I think about this dog.
If people came from monkeys and monkeys is still here.
What the fuck a monkey's doing?
Why are they still here?
How come there's still monkeys?
If we came from monkeys,
Shit's impossible.
He's like a black show.
He did is he's,
he's his own thing.
He talks about you follow into the fall.
Joey's stories.
You will,
it makes sense too.
He's funny though.
When I saw him in the days we've talked about Eddie Griffin on the podcast too
many times.
Sorry folks.
But just,
you got to get to let shit go where it goes.
When,
uh,
when I first met Eddie Griffin,
that was in when he first just did his HBO special dude.
He was so fucking good that each real special.
I don't know if it holds up.
I said this before,
I haven't seen it since I saw it back then,
but when I saw it back then it was like,
this is one dynamic fucking entertainer.
Like this dude is little and skinny and he was moving around quick and I was
like,
wow.
He was just a fucking star.
It's like an undeniable star.
It was like boom.
But I've never met a dude so crazy.
I know.
So much fun.
Yeah,
he is so crazy.
But he's really cool.
He had a cigarette in his hand and we're the backstage of the comedy store.
Like I did 12 rounds today with a kickboxing champion.
Yeah.
For the first six rounds I've met it.
He got the best domain.
But NIGGA didn't want no mon the last six.
You know what I'm saying?
He didn't want no mo and he's drinking and he's got a cigarette and I'm like,
here's a movie star.
And he's making up a story about fighting a kickboxing champion.
Right.
I just think he would just get drunk and just see if he could fuck with you.
I just think he was like creating stories in his mind.
I don't even think he was really lying to you.
I think it was just for him.
I'm a have a good time.
I'm just going to talk some crazy shit.
You know?
It was just,
I mean it wasn't,
you know,
he was,
he was like,
it wasn't committed to the theory either.
You could change him.
He could change his opinion.
You know,
like we had,
we had a conversation once about the pyramids.
He's like,
the pyramids were created with sound.
That's what you don't know.
The pyramids were creaky.
You did with sound.
They use harmonic resonance and Magneto,
he's making some shit up and they moved those stones into place.
And I said,
they don't know how they moved those stones in the place,
but they think they might've been cement that was poured to the deal with the
stones is the incredible numbers.
2,300,000 so I just start fucking hitting him with all these facts.
So it's of kind of being douchey about it yet,
but it's just one of my pet subjects.
And I hate when people talk nonsense about the parents.
Right?
So I go into mining,
even been poured limestone,
it might not even been cut,
but there is.
So I tell him all this shit.
He goes,
but what,
how many stones?
So he goes on stage 10 minutes later,
the pyramids you telling me 2,300,000 stones are cut perfectly.
He was just absorb.
It just seems like,
you know,
he just would,
who changed his opinion?
Like you could,
you could tell him that he was wrong and we go,
okay,
I'm going to talk about that now.
And he's got this very evangelical quality to him.
We can talk about anything.
He could happen 10 minutes before and he would go onstage and he would just fire
off about it.
You know,
that was one of the fun things about the comedy store.
it don't get me wrong what I'm saying.
I mean like when I'm telling that he does this mean he does and it's all most of
his own shit.
I mean,
I'm not saying that he's taking anybody's ideas or anything.
What I'm saying is that he's just a fascinating character.
He would like,
he was like,
he'd move in and out,
you know what I mean?
He would like be brilliant and then be crazy,
but when he was brilliant,
you're like,
Whoa,
where's this?
It's fucking amazing,
dude.
He would hit some notes,
man.
Oh,
crazy dude.
I seen that guy destroyed in a way where I'm like,
wow,
this guy's like really special.
He's got a special talent.
Yup.
He had some killer jokes,
but my favorite one is the one about about cocaine and cocaine being involved
with the invention of the telephone that go.
He goes,
he goes,
because you've got to be high like a mother fucker to be sitting around going,
I want to talk to someone who's not even here.
That's a great fucking joke.
I saw him light that fucking comedy store original room up with that joke.
You've got gotta be high like a mother fucker with a cigarette in his hand to be
sitting around going,
I want to talk to somebody who I am.
And he would just hit them with this perfect facial expression.
I'd be like,
God,
it was humbling.
You know,
it's like my early days of news radio in 1994 you know,
and I was like my act as like weak kind of work on my act.
I got to tighten it up and they see a guy like that,
you know,
you'd see a few guys that you'd see perform.
So Damon Wayans crack some out of the park.
Damon Wayans is one of the most underrated guys ever do when Damon Wayans did
his HBO special.
That is a funny fucking special.
That still holds up.
It's still pretty fun.
Yeah.
His stuff is always good to ship.
Talking about meet Tommy Hearns and about meeting Mike Tyson and Mike Tyson was
mad at him cause he was making jokes about them.
You know,
it's funny fucking shit man.
It's good.
I don't want to fuck it up.
I don't want to go it.
But it's like some lab designed him a punch of Mickey liver be you think you're
funny?
But he goes,
he started biting me.
That was what he said.
He biting him and I think it was before the event or Holyfield in Sudan.
I think he might've made this special before Tyson bit Holyfield's ear.
I'm not sure which is even crazier if he did,
but it was a funny fucking special mat.
This had a bunch of good shit in it.
I watched it the other day was unlike these are your online,
I can't remember if I saw it online,
if I saw it on the TV,
but it was,
he's underrated man.
He was one of those guys that for whatever reason got famous for movies and got
famous for a lot of stuff.
But when he was on like as a standup,
he was fucking great man.
He was great.
Like he was really good.
It's just shocking to me how few people recognize that.
You know?
I've never seen it.
I don't think I've ever,
I don't think I've seen him do stand reeling dude.
You got to watch his,
I think it's called last stand.
I think that's what it's called.
Um,
like I said,
I just saw it the other day for the first time in years and it was really good,
man.
I was like,
this stuff is,
he's a sole likable and his whole relaxed on stage and just he's had just a real
comic man,
you know?
It just doesn't really get the credit that he deserves for that.
I think,
I mean,
I,
I just,
you know,
contradict myself because I always say that people get exactly the credit that
they deserve because,
you know,
no one should,
people who like,
you know,
he doesn't get enough credit,
but yeah,
it does.
You know,
he's fucking,
somehow or another,
he's not connecting to people,
you know,
he's not,
he's not putting it out or he's not getting it broadcast.
Like he's got to figure it out.
He just,
he can't just be good.
You have to,
everybody has to know you're good.
You have to let everybody know.
There's something out there that again,
hey,
I like this guy here.
You could see what he does on Youtube and it's gotta be something out there to
connect to people if you're not doing it,
you know?
Do you see ll cool j last night on Conan O'brien?
Something's weird with that guy,
you know one got it.
Find a clip or watch their habits.
Well he was just acting very crazy and then like not anything insane,
but like you were just kind of watching him really.
Something's not right.
Like maybe he went too far in some kind of drug or something.
But he was talking about,
he was at this play recently in La,
like a month ago.
I did not hear about this.
And in the play there's this part where like this wall falls down or something
like that,
right?
It's wobbling.
And he saw this wall starting to fall down and he runs on stage grabs this woman
tries to get her to protect her from this wall.
And the woman's like,
you're ruining my,
my show,
you know,
in the middle of a play.
And he got kicked out and everything like that.
But he's telling the story and I'm like,
this can't be true.
I googled it and then sure enough there was like newspaper articles about ll
cool j.
It goes crazy and jumps on stage of play.
We must have been so high unless it was so high.
He was like,
this fucking wall.
It's going to kill the kids.
He's going to die.
I'm fucking ll cool J.
I'm to jump up there and shit.
Yeah.
And he just seemed very positive on the Coney.
He was just like,
I just love everything I do.
I like,
he like he,
he looks like he was anti depressants.
Yeah.
That's what it seemed like.
I got to see it now.
Pull that shit up on,
come on.
Find how to find that Conan O'Brien's episode last night.
Um,
Google.
Maybe try to put it together.
Brian,
come on.
You're a web genius.
Do you think it's available online?
If it's that weird,
see him.
Somebody probably did it right?
Oh,
probably not.
I mean,
maybe it was just me.
I don't know.
I'll find it though.
You think it was?
Maybe it was just you that thought it was help.
Wait a minute.
Stop.
How high were you when this was happening?
No,
I was,
I was not sure.
I was not,
I was not high.
It just like he was being weird and then,
then he told that story and then it was like,
wow,
there's something really weird is going on.
We pay full attention or will you semi masturbating while you're watching this?
I was laying in,
laying in bed.
If you leave a man by himself alone in a room with a TV on,
80% of his time will be spent semi masturbating.
You know,
I'm just saying,
Hey,
I'm just going to run mumbles.
It feels good and no one's here.
So will you tell the truth bro?
I was just laying in bed actually,
so it'd be weird as fuck on.
He got nervous watching an ll cool j,
uh,
past videos.
You just created this fucking dilemma laying in bed with your tramp dog.
So was it actually an effect that he didn't recognize it?
Was that what was going on or did he actually write?
It was an effect that he thought was really happening.
Like a wall was falling down and he grabbed in the actress,
oh boy.
Maybe just wanting to try to fuck her real quick.
He apologized and he said,
you know,
I,
so he's like,
I'm really embarrassed about the whole situation,
but I'm thinking,
really,
you're at a play.
Why would you ever think that?
Still in the middle of the plate.
Ll Cool j such a bad motherfucker and has so much confidence that you might've
just wanted to fuck that check and said,
mom,
I just rescue a real quick or pretend to and then a fucker.
And then can you imagine being at your play and ll cool j jumps out.
Fuck you.
Imagine doing a play.
Okay,
it's 2010 we don't need that shit anymore.
Stupid.
Very realistic.
Collapsing walls.
Yeah,
that Shit's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's like Morse code.
We don't need it anymore.
I don't need that shit.
We've got way better shit than place.
That's like cave painting.
Stupid.
Stop it.
You know,
man,
that's it.
That's one of the bad things about living in la.
No gay place,
you will inevitably get invited to one of your actor friends death.
And it is deck I went to,
I went to one with my brother and it was so bad and it was just very serious,
very serious part.
That's super serious part.
And my brother is tr,
you know when you're with someone and they're trying not to laugh and you look
over and you see and then you're trying not to laugh at the same time.
So in the middle of this play,
which is about the witch burnings and this woman's doing this very dramatic
monologue about the witch burnings.
I look over and my brother's like,
God,
his fist balled up and it looks like he's crying.
Like he was being a fag.
Worse ma'am.
Cause he was trying not to laugh so hard.
He was actually,
we both work.
Cause if you laughed,
it would be that it's a tiny little black box and you would just look like the
biggest asshole Brian Callen took me to,
he had this acting teacher and this acting teacher was a fan of musicals.
And though he claimed to be married to a woman,
I had questions.
So anyway,
that's neither here nor there.
So we go to this,
this show that this guy puts on and Brian says,
I got to stop by my acting coach real quick.
He's got this thing going on.
Come with me.
It'll be fun.
Okay.
What is it?
Well,
it's,
it's just this thing he said,
but I'd like,
he sings,
he's them.
He likes musicals.
It's kind of,
it's gonna be cool.
It's going to go,
I'll go in there real quick.
I'll say hi and then we'll go and then we'll go.
Okay.
So I go,
I have no idea what I'm getting into.
Okay.
We're high as fucking Paula Abdul on the ride home from the pharmacy having sex
with Jesus and space.
Okay,
we're fucking ballistically smashed.
You know,
this was the early days in my pot smoking too,
where I just wouldn't go deep to way too many times I would go like in public
are just way too high.
Right?
We should be a home at home under the covers with the lights out.
Okay.
I should be in my jammies and here I am just wondering around with seeing random
things.
So this guy goes on stage and he's wearing those slip on shoes.
I hate like when I see men with those slip on dress shoes with the hardwood and
he'll,
you know,
those little s wouldn't,
you know those are things.
Yeah,
they're almost as bad as the frog shoes.
The sandals.
I know what you're talking about.
A penny loafers pending offers yet.
And then wearing them with little skinny black socks like that is not
comfortable.
That's an uncomfortable shit.
What the fuck are you doing?
Why do you have to wear that stupid thing for business?
Like what are you doing now?
You're out singing anywhere and he's stupid fucking shoes.
And this is just me though.
That's weird thing about people dressing like,
you know,
business.
He,
you know,
I'm like,
this is a,
you're trying to like appear to be something to me.
So he's singing,
he gets on stage and he starts saying,
and this is what he sings,
songs that are in musicals.
That's what I mean.
One,
one of them walk,
fuck.
One of the lyrics was he was like singing a song like to a little girl,
like as dumb.
It might've been a daughter or something like that.
And it was like,
breathe when you need to breathe.
Like that was one of the lines.
What was Brian Cowen doing?
We were biting our hands by their hands and my toes were curling under
themselves.
It was that one of the most bizarre forms of entertainment I've ever seen in my
life.
One man singing a bunch of show tunes to his friends and then his students and
his students friends all in the little,
it was in a theater?
No,
it was in the,
the um,
the Roosevelt hotel.
You know the place in the Roosevelt hotel.
Roosevelt.
I know what you're talking about.
What we were doing.
Comedy.
I remember we were doing comedy there for a while.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
Jay Davis,
his place.
Remember that he had that room.
It was really cool room.
Interesting.
Well,
this is where the guy,
it was like a cabaret act.
Yes,
yes.
And it was the one of the fucking girls things I've ever seen in my life.
And of course Brian didn't want to leave.
I can't leave.
I've got to,
which is to stay,
stay,
stay.
Really.
He was too high.
He didn't want to,
we were just panicking about going out and facing the outside world.
So we sat and watched this thing go down for like an hour.
How did the guy get the ll cool j audio,
by the way?
Oh,
you do?
It's really this interesting.
Okay.
Well I mean it's,
you can just listen to it a little bit of how positive and drug.
Oh,
another thing is is he's not sponsored by this Cologne,
but he brings his favorite Cologne that he's like,
I've been wearing this all my life to give it Conan as a precedent.
I am so curious as to whether I'm going agree with you on how he's behaving.
Um,
it'd be better if you,
uh,
looked at the video.
I go,
okay,
let me come over on Dunkin seat for a second.
He just seems very happy drug,
like super happy.
Like it's almost creepy.
We're playing musical chairs here.
People,
well Dunkin has to go on pay fucking child.
Doug has got a weak bladder and we're going to have to get you one of them.
New Bladders.
[inaudible]
can everybody else hear this term?
I'm really hearing it through the microphone.
It's my favorite Cologne.
Ah,
buffering.
Really?
No,
I just wear old spice
is for faggots.
Carry on.
I'm just kidding.
Will flock to me now.
Oh cool.
Thanks so much for being here.
Congratulations on all your success.
Share your shows.
A massive hit saying we're all very happy for you.
I'm grateful.
Congratulations to you.
Thank you.
We're having a blast here and I wanted to,
I wanted to say
[inaudible]
in a
Brian I did.
I read about
what's the story?
Give me the story.
I want to see also the nonsense and he just had to read about was it going to
lead right into it right there?
Who wants to try it?
You bought the portrait and then you loaned it out to the Smithsonian.
This is amazing.
It looks very,
is that him?
He looks like he had sex with biggie smalls
magazine.
Your kitchen.
That's it.
This is whack editing son.
I'm going to get back to my seat and he looks pretty normal to me.
I must have been masturbating.
I forgot.
It's not as cool as I remembered it last night.
I just remembered thinking,
I just remember thinking ll cool j is cracked out and then he tells us this man.
He sounds totally normal.
You were high as fuck.
This is evidence.
You need to get your shit together.
You got chem trails over your house,
boy Trey and I'm fucking with your head.
It's a government man to government.
Brian Kelly,
Brian,
ll cool J.
I have met him once when I was on news radio and seem like a fine young man.
You're making them out to be a God damn crackhead.
What do you think of it?
Totally normal except for the story about him jumping on in the middle of a play
or maybe it was a little high then,
bro.
Well maybe he's just a super nice guy.
Looks do cool shit.
Or maybe just thought,
let me just fuck this chick quick,
quick.
She'll pull down,
grab her belief on,
come on the era.
Come with me.
He's a handsome man.
He's all yoked and shit.
Maybe you just takes chances.
I always liked listening to ll cool J's old songs cause he used to always rap
about ice cream and puppy dogs.
Do you remember that?
He'll just throw him like puppy dogs and ice cream in the middle of a song.
You're just,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh there's old stuff.
He always talks about ice cream and licking lips.
Don't call where's Mama said knock you out.
That's a great fucking song.
I don't care.
As long as I don't hear it too often.
You know here like once every couple of years,
that song is the shit man.
You know what someone don't call it a comeback now.
He had like some angry,
confident wraps,
you know,
he had some fun shit.
He was good man.
He's a really good rapper.
You know,
I enjoy it.
A bunch of his fucking songs,
so I don't appreciate you talking shit about him Brian.
Especially when it's so poorly researched.
You need to study that shit whilst sober young man.
You're just terrified of anything black.
It's all my talking about black dicks on his podcast while staring in your eyes.
It's like there's this,
it's like nom to me.
I see a black person on the TV and I just think of you and black dicks chasing
me down a hallway with some guy in prison and I'm ripping it and pause off and I
can't stop your,
you're fucking,
yeah,
you're an anti rape tech type prison rape.
A ball grabbing.
I've got an email from somebody asked me to not say rape,
rape,
rape.
Why use rape?
It's an unpleasant thought.
It's an unpleasant,
you know,
I mean,
what if somebody Murphy,
one of your loved ones had been raped?
Would you still use rape?
Who the fun sends that email?
Well,
you know,
maybe he had somebody that was raped.
I mean,
it's a good point.
I guess what he's raping your eyeballs with that email.
Is it,
does he send emails to everyone who uses that word?
Maybe.
I mean,
I didn't ask.
Was he trying to eliminate,
they get too many emails to ask questions,
man.
That I didn't,
didn't Cicada I don't know.
I don't know.
Don't mean,
is that a valid idea?
The idea that,
you know,
saying something that could hurt someone's feelings when you could have an
alternative word that maybe wouldn't be ideal for the expression that you try
to,
if we were to going to show four king king rapey no man for me.
Come on.
What percentage of the guidance sent that email?
Can you repeat the worst case?
You know what you're getting?
At least
you know his name is king hugs and cuddles as a fucking barbarian.
He likes to fuck kids in the ass and chop their heads off when he comes.
Moreau word.
Yeah,
I mean better to be called that.
Right.
So you know exactly what you're getting.
And you know what,
let me come back and we were talking about before when you're talking about
this,
all this pillaging talk,
you know when we're talking about the vikings and shit,
so you think that's what,
that's what killed the Roman Empire,
right?
Well it seems like there's a bunch of different empires did the exact same
thing,
right?
Like the Greeks,
same thing.
They had fantastic structures.
They never repaired them.
Everything went to shit.
And then civilization of stayed in the same
area but became completely vastly different.
Right?
Yeah.
Isn't that amazing?
They got these incredible structures,
like some of the most amazing things that people have ever built ever.
Right.
The Acropolis,
Acropolis and the Parthenon Mirror amazing,
beautiful artwork there.
Sculptures and shit.
And then they just kind of stopped doing that and let it all fall to shit.
Like they forgot how to repair those buildings.
The same p.
And you know what I'm saying?
People are still living there who's never unpopulated where it was like a barren
wasteland and nuclear bomb blew off and people couldn't live there for a fucking
100,000 years.
No people stayed in that same area,
but they never figured out how to fix all that shit.
They just kind of let it fall apart and nobody owns it.
I mean somebody owns it obviously.
I mean they,
they have tourism and shit,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like nobody owned it to fix it,
you know,
hey,
this is my shit.
I got to fix this fucking thing.
What?
The building's falling apart,
you know?
Okay,
let's get some workers to work on the coliseum.
No,
they built the coliseum and then just fucked off.
You know,
you know,
I can remember right when this is it we're in right now.
He started to kind of go into this collapsed and it was like three,
I don't remember how many years ago it was,
but I remember like sitting in a movie theater and looking down and there's this
rip in the seat and I looked over and there to rip and then another seat and I
was like,
you know,
that's different.
Like that would normally be repaired.
It's,
it was like things are kind of fraying at the edges a little bit.
A while ago and now what you're talking about is happening here much more like
if you,
if you look around when you're,
when you're,
when you're out looking at dirty,
the cars are,
I know that sounds stupid,
but people aren't washing their cars.
Like cars are really cost money to wash your car.
People have a lot of money now and things are really getting dilapidated.
You can kind of see this kind of added this.
Paul is sending over things that I've never seen in my whole life.
I've never seen that shit before.
We've never been a part of a recession before.
Right.
You know,
we never been a part of when the fake system falls apart and then they have to
kind of rebuild,
but they don't really rebuild the rebuild on the same structure of what I call
unfixable bullshit.
You know,
the stock market,
the economy,
the political system that we have.
It's all like,
you're going to rebuild the society on this fucking house of lies.
You know,
we've got to figure out a new way to do things.
And when I'm looking at these other civilizations,
like the Greeks and the Romans,
the ones that risen and fell like look at the Egyptian.
Same thing.
You know,
when they discovered those ruins,
those ruins the parent.
There's no one living in them.
They're just,
they're just giant monuments that had been taking open and they'd been,
you know,
people would read them and stolen all the artifacts and stuff and sold them,
but there was,
there's no one living in there.
Those are the most amazing structures human beings have ever created.
And their civilization devolved to the point where people moved out.
That's a,
that's a pretty incredible,
it's pretty incredible.
Most amazing civilization ever.
And it fell apart so much.
So there was no one living there.
All right.
What the Mayans too right now,
the is to doing very,
very interesting and similar story.
They don't know exactly what happened with the Mayans.
They,
you know,
the Mayans weren't like,
like someone said,
oh they were,
they were killed.
But no,
that's not true.
They don't know.
They don't know what happened to the mines.
It appears like the man's just left.
That's why all these nutty fucking lizard reptilian believe in.
So they were in a space ship.
They came and [inaudible] took them on a fiery serpent serpent with feathers,
right?
The feathered serpent.
A chordal.
Yeah.
That's quick sit quite,
yeah.
Quite so Quadel.
Yeah.
There was a movie called model.
There was a movie called cue and I liked when I was a kid,
which is about a Kwikset Quadel attacking.
I said,
hey,
it's really great.
Yeah,
it's called Q.
Oh yeah.
He's telling me it's on iTunes.
I don't know.
It's like an old school movie.
And it's like,
oh,
I must Google that right now.
Needs to make a Queso quatro fucking movie,
man.
I already gave you your bitches.
A Wolf Werewolf on a plane.
Although I heard that that chuck power on the hook and the,
what's his name,
the guy who wrote fight club,
the guy who wrote,
he wrote,
um,
oh,
I know you're telling me you famous authors to bring a bunch of great books.
He made a scene and,
and then someone actually sent me the scene.
I thought it was inventing a beautiful moment.
A guy,
a girl.
I was a in a on a flight once and a girl had a seizure and I was like,
what does she turn into a Werewolf fuck?
Could you imagine being on a plane?
And so apparently chuck Pyle and a Hook knuck everybody's name is a fantastic
writer,
already thought of it.
Damn the fucker.
He had it.
He made it even creepier cause it was a little girl.
That motherfucker,
it's really up to me,
up to me and he's genius.
Well,
it's pretty the coolest scripture,
the way you described it to,
he's got a really,
a harsh way of,
uh,
of depicting things where it's like,
it just,
there's like no judgment to it.
It's just,
this is what's happening.
You know,
it's like,
here it is.
It's like,
whoa.
You know,
like you read his shit.
I love writers like that because he's like that fucking love that.
I just started watching a documentary on B calcium.
Which one?
I'll tell you,
it's on my iTunes because I was watching it on the plane and I was enjoying it
up into a point that I was like,
God damn,
this motherfucker was negative at certain points.
I was like,
dude,
bring it on yourself,
bitch.
Born into this
barn and tireless,
I had a recording of him reading his poetry and somebody who was heckling him
for whatever reason and all of a sudden he's,
he just stops and he's like,
I've got a blade in my pocket and I will cut you.
Man.
He was serious.
Shrunk.
It was totally serious.
Like he was,
he was like ready to fight cause he was a bar brawl brawl with people and he did
it on purpose.
Like his whole idea was that it got to live.
You got fuck,
uh,
get drunk.
Yeah.
Can't just fucking shit this out.
And this really crazy way of looking at life that you had,
he was willing to like believe a wild life or his writing.
Well he reminds me of like a zen master.
Like if you read zen poetry and like this pure crisp description of reality
that's theirs.
It's the same kind of thing,
but he's just talking about filthy whore tenements and people were like,
well that's not good.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's just not good for him.
First of all,
I ate a pot cookie on the plane so it was not the best time to be watching
something like this.
Just guys on negative,
God damn so crazy,
but he's negative.
Ever get scared of that though,
that you're going to eat the wrong strongest cookie ever.
One time it happened many times I've learned some of the greatest lessons about
life,
little prizes,
like I get scared by those trips,
but those trips teach me everything.
That's where I learn.
Totally.
Cause you don't listen.
You wouldn't normally invite that onto yourself,
etc. Or whatever reason.
You eat too much and then you're like going into the fucking grader.
There's layers upon layers of denial and a good pot cookie will wipe out nearly
all them bitches nearly all and fucking shine some lights on,
some shit you forgot about.
And it's healing too.
It's like,
you know,
everyone talks about how marijuana has medicinal and I never understood that
until I ate a lot of pot and was a,
was like laying down and I really felt as though,
or like going through my psyche and doing a defrag or something,
I was like put,
you know,
it's like,
um,
it was like cleaning up stuff and like getting rid of the bullshit and it really
like for weeks after that I felt a million times happier.
It,
it really is like medicine for the ego.
Yeah.
It's like ego tablets.
Ego's been lying to you here,
take this and you could see what's going on.
Oh look,
you've got all this happening here.
I know this is why you won't do that.
And you know,
you don't clean your office because you don't want to come to the consequences
of being a success.
And you know,
if
you let go what your fucking parents did,
they were stupid.
They were young too.
Okay.
Fuck yeah.
It's almost like an grudge.
It's almost like a coach standing right next to you tie that in a tank.
That's where it's at.
Dude.
That's where it's how we can have a way better world if people would just,
I need to make a duck and it's not a documentary thing.
I need to make something happen where more people get access to these tanks and
like document it,
set these tanks up all over the place,
get,
get people involved in them and get them to get high as fuck and go in there and
get them to reevaluate their life.
You should do it as AI.
It would be awesome is if you can figure out a way to do that with prisons.
C three you get prisoners make the water dirty.
No,
you gotta you gotta,
you know?
No,
that's too much work.
It's work,
but it's like,
to me that's the,
I've always thought that if they,
if they need a bunch of steps before they get the isolation tanks,
you can't just let dude's fucking climate a tank of water dudes with jumping in
there with them and,
but fucking him.
She'd have to control all that.
Would have way too much salt in it.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not in favor of rewarding prisoners would shit that.
I don't think it to figure out a way to,
uh,
you know,
counsel them to,
integrate them back in society.
And I don't think the system that they have right now is the right way to do it.
But if I was a fucking victim or the family of a victim and there's some dude
who's getting an isolation tank and I can't afford it,
I'd be like,
fuck you.
You know,
I don't think they deserve that shit.
It's just you,
you have to punish people and you have to set an example for doing shitty things
as long as it's not like drug related nonviolent crimes,
you know,
like,
oh,
he had a of pot on him,
now he's
in jail.
You know,
that kind of nonsense when you watch locked up raw and you see the way these
guys are being treated,
they're freaking out.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
It's like,
okay,
I get it.
Vengeance.
And I understand that desire for vengeance from the family,
but isn't there like a bigger picture here?
Which is that,
yeah,
you want vengeance,
but that's just part of the same problem is that this part of the same problem,
but the problem is this person is not going to get any better if you let them
out and they don't learn anything from this,
they don't suffer.
And guess what?
Nothing changed it and you leave them in what?
Nothing changes either.
They didn't beat up.
I don't think they learn anything from the current way they they're treated,
but at least the victims have the satisfaction of knowing that this person has
to pay for their suffering,
which is great until that fucking person gets let out.
It would have been don't ever four months,
but a lot of them do.
Yes.
Suddenly.
So now you got your,
your your fucking pound of flesh.
This guy got raped for 10 years.
He got addicted to foot,
some weird drug and now he's out in the streets and he's going to do it again.
Yeah.
And then that spreads more.
That spreads more of taking like very,
very like very specific examples.
But it's more important than anything to protect people from people that want to
harm them.
That's the most important thing.
So if anybody's is violent,
if anybody's dangerous,
they need to be locked up.
And if they don't learn or if you don't think that they're there,
they have a real objective assessment.
And I think that this guy is going to go back and get revenge,
should never be let out.
Well,
I was reading Mckenna talking about you.
How do you diagnose that?
I was correctly make that call and not imprison someone for life because you
don't like them.
But leary and uh,
back in the 60s,
they were doing experiments with,
I don't know if it was LSD or psilocybin with prisoners,
and the effect was tremendous.
It was changing them and transforming them.
I'm sure.
And so that's what I'm saying.
It's like that's a better option.
Yeah.
Hank is too complicated.
The tank.
You need too much control of yourself.
You need to be able to be calm and relaxed.
You need to be able to let go,
to use it.
You need to not piss and jerk off in there.
You fuckhead
you know what I'm saying?
Right.
You don't want to leave that to the prisoners and I flotation thing.
I think we all agree on that.
Giving the mushrooms will be a way,
Chet,
and way better solution and a really good one.
I mean if you wanted to reintegrate them,
you can just create an alternate society.
We're looking,
you can't ever go free,
but how about we only have the mushroom taking population segmented off from the
rest of everybody else and we'll give you guys a chance to reestablish a
community.
We have a giant track of land.
You have gps trips on.
Don't try to escape.
We're going to put the GPS trip into muscular and your body,
if you cut it out,
it will register in the computer.
You go back to jail for the rest of your term plus parole.
No questions asked.
So take the mushrooms and you live in this little place in the village like a
fucking m night Shama Lama Ding Dong movie.
And everybody goes out there by themselves,
completely disconnected from society.
And let's do it as an experiment.
Let's take all these fucked up prisoners and make them eat mushrooms,
take the most violent,
the most fucked up,
the craziest and let them talk to the spirit world.
Five grams all the time,
all day sun,
all day sun.
We're going to watch them evolve right before [inaudible] gain trips every
month,
every month they have scheduled people game trips.
These motherfuckers are going to do
IOWASCA.
We're going to give them a full psychedelic reevaluation,
but how amazing would it be if instead of having to send them to their plot of
land,
what if when people came out of prison,
because we were so advanced and we understood the psychology so well,
people came out of prison.
They were like professors.
There were a million times better and then there are helping society.
Problem is there's too many.
There's not enough money.
There's too many,
there's too many fucking people.
There's too many people that are so far gone.
You're going to have to do something special to make them change.
That's where my mushroom plantation comes in.
I like,
I like the Rogan mushroom plantation,
but I think that Duncan Trussell LSD egg is much better,
which is an egg shaped thing that prisoners go in for many,
many years until their egos completely erased there reprogrammed with only
positive teachings.
They learn about Buddhism,
all the world religions and they,
you pop them back out into society.
Maybe you start with six,
seven but you pop them back out into society and now instead of putting the
poison back into society,
you're putting a,
an antidote.
Well that's a beautiful idea in theory,
but that's so far away from being able to be done.
You know,
we're talking science fiction there.
It's not,
I mean it's not science fiction.
I mean that's not yet.
We're not yet capable of it,
but mushrooms are here right now.
That's what I'm saying.
This site within inducing,
so you're,
you're saying this is a much,
I lost you.
What I'm saying.
What I'm saying is you put prisoners in some sort of like chamber,
I don't know what you're saying.
Like you inject them with it or something and you just like have them.
It's exactly the same thing you said.
I was just still,
I was being a little too uh weird about it because then you would created some
alternate reality where you can waste their memories.
No,
I think if you gave someone enough LSD you would raise their memory.
But in my,
in my mind it's like an like an egg like thing where you pretty attached to this
is where he lost weight.
I know it was like what did he die?
I don't know why I see like the spicy,
it's like this egg like thing and you project on the walls,
just beautiful images.
It's like a more gag he came out.
Yeah,
so it's a mortgage.
Nailed it son.
That's it.
Pulled out the greatest all time references a mark egg.
I didn't remember that.
A more egg was a real thing until you brought that up.
Well the morgue equity and I've always wanted one of those.
No because we do give some knuckles on the mortgage reference.
But you guys both need to try and read Ben Prison idea because it was way better
than the Duncan Trussell prison idea.
What does it just make them bomb sniffer dogs and taking,
you know,
use prisoners for things like that.
Like,
okay,
we might have a bomb in here.
By the way,
we were talking about,
um,
the,
uh,
the LSD experiments.
We were talking about the MK Ultra.
Yeah.
We were talking about the shit that they did,
the CIA that turned Ted Kaczynski into the Unabomber supposedly allegedly.
Um,
the documentary and we talked about in the podcast before,
I think the documentary is called the net.
Very,
very fascinating.
Really interesting shit.
So that's what my problem with Lsd,
my palm with LSD is I keep hearing crazy stories about people losing their
marbles,
you know,
and Howard Stern's talked about it,
how he took it once and he took too much of it and he had this horrifying scary
fucking trip.
I,
and where he was like losing his mind.
And then the drummer from pink Floyd,
the Joey Diaz always talks about,
did some fucking LSD lost his mind?
I don't remember the dude's name.
Sid Barrett.
Is that his name?
Yeah.
Do you know the whole story?
I don't think it was a drummer,
but yeah,
I know,
I know.
What did he,
was the guitar player,
was he?
No,
he,
he was like a singer and I think he was like one of the founders of it or
something.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
the story goes that he just,
they were all tripping out so much,
but he,
I think he became a schizophrenia or a shut in and London or something.
And then he's,
he died,
he's deputy release him.
Great.
The,
um,
Syd Barrett,
or at least some snows do or the allegedly believed it was due to an LSD trip.
Like it was.
It was,
can they say it was,
he went crazy from it.
He did like Lsd and just lost his mother.
See,
you know,
you hear about them,
you don't hear about that with mushrooms.
Right.
Although that's not totally true because Dennis Mckenna,
Terence Mckenna's brother apparently lost it for a long time.
They had some big crazy mushroom trip down in central America or South America,
and he was gone for like two weeks where he was like in this complete like fit
of madness.
It was just a,
shit happens a lot with mushrooms.
Yeah.
Growing up,
and when I used to do mushrooms,
a lie,
a lot of my friends had the same shit where you're like,
what happened to so and so?
And like,
oh,
I haven't seen him for like a week.
And they knew it came.
He comes back and say,
dude,
I had,
it's a really bad trip.
I just sat in my house for a week and thought about things.
Oh,
I've had that a few times at the top.
That is,
um,
do you think that Dennis,
just an overwhelming amount of silicide Ben and they just couldn't process it,
or do you think that it was a very bad time in their life when they took it?
And then there's some sort of an internal struggle between the experience of
psychedelic experience,
which requires absolute truth and honesty and all the issues that you might have
not resolved in your own mind?
They're constantly fucking with your psyche.
So then a battle takes place between the psychedelic truth and all the shit that
you're trying to keep him in the closet in the dark and all the douchey behavior
and all life and stress and death and it's sucking dicks and airplanes getting
hit by missiles and it all just falls apart and your mind literally cannot grab
anything.
It's just madness where this like defragging before your eyes and information is
crumbling.
Your ability to decode the language,
it's all desolving like you fuck your whole brain sideways.
And apparently for like two weeks he was gone.
But that's when you need a Sharman or somebody,
somebody could talk you down,
lead you through that because that means you're at the right place.
That's when the healing starts is they've pulled all the fuck there.
There's scrubbing the terms of your ego away and all of a sudden you're in this
open place and if you're with someone who knows what they're doing,
who really knows what they're doing,
then you can like evolve at that moment and become something like so much
happier and more real than you are.
It's just,
that's the sad thing about it is no one knows how to do that.
And that's,
the kids are like fucking tripping on psychedelics and
having rotten trips.
Yeah.
No one knows how to.
They don't know.
They don't know how to do it.
And also they're coming from a who you know,
who knows what their view of the world is and how far it is off from reality.
And that's one thing about all psychedelic trips is they force you.
Before we go any further,
I'd like to see your ticket and I'd like to see your ticket is here is your real
life for real.
Okay.
So before we go and talk to any fucking flying blue dragons and a take you into
the center of the universe and,
and show you the,
the fabric of life.
It's under the hood of the car of the universe.
Before we do that,
here's you.
I think sometimes the drugs affect different people in different ways.
Other than that though,
I think I've said this before,
this girl I knew,
she hit one,
you know,
bong once and she just took off running as fast as she could into my bathroom
and hit the tub and fell against the wall and stuff.
But when she came back to it,
she was like,
I don't remember doing it.
I have no idea why I did that.
And I'm like,
what one hit from we made you do this.
Don't ever touch we'd ever again.
Yeah,
you're right,
man.
Look,
Stan hope doesn't like weed.
You know,
he'll tell you I don't like what it does to me.
Yeah.
And Santo Bikes,
everything.
I mean,
he's a mushroom efficient.
Mando you know,
he's,
he's probably taken 30 times more drugs and I have,
he'll hope to fucking take anything.
I heard this story,
I was reading the biography of Timothy leary and I can't remember the name of it
now.
There's a bunch of them,
I'm sure.
But the one I was reading,
there was a reporter who was at the house where they were all tripping out and
um,
he was like watching them.
He's kind of like a net.
He was like apparently going to do a negative story on them or something.
Um,
cause you know,
as a,
you know,
leary was up in this house with a bunch of hippies like,
uh,
Alan Ginsburg and Richard Alpert and like a lot of the,
the beat to people from the 60s and they were all experimenting with acid.
But this reporter apparently snuck into Timothy Leary's office where under his
office in a drawer and the cantor,
he had a liquid acid,
no,
it thinking it was vodka or some kind of alcohol poured himself a drink.
Yeah.
Wow.
Oh my God,
yes.
Did this massive amount of acid not even knowing it.
And so we started having this incredibly terrible trip and they say he took his
clothes off.
He was running around the grounds naked,
but they got him to sit down and uh,
fucking,
uh,
Alan Ginsburg and I can't remember who the other people,
where they all started singing Hari Krishna to this guy,
the Hari Krishna Maha Mantra,
which is how do Christianity,
Christian and Christian Christian,
Yada,
seeing that shit come on.
You know how to say,
I haven't terrible how to do all this shit.
Got The Beatles,
dude,
you need to do it.
You know how to do it well,
no,
you do it all the time.
You don't know.
The thing about Hari Krishna is you can sing it,
which is called a curtain,
but you don't have to sing.
It sounds cool.
You know how to do it.
It's cool.
It's cooler to channel.
Okay,
go ahead.
But you all have to change it with them.
So it goes Hari Krishna haunted,
complete.
Don't weigh that.
Don't play that for a second.
Cause it really is a serious bro.
Fucking serious.
Not Serious,
but it's kind of psychedelic Internet is serious business.
Trying to get you guys see cats everywhere.
I say that.
Um,
hit me with it.
So it goes hardy,
Krishna,
Hari Krishna,
Krishna.
Howdy.
Howdy Dharma.
Hari Rama,
Rama,
Rama.
Howdy.
Christian.
Aniko sneakers Nickerson and got it wrong.
And I don't remember.
I remember that.
Oh,
here's an easier,
when he was another mantra,
which is,
okay,
is it good when it's just rom our aim to go wrong,
wrong,
fast.
Well,
however you want to do it.
Rum,
rum,
wrong,
wrong.
I think we're too high.
I'd be doing a podcast.
The fact that we were even considering that,
that might be entertaining for other people.
Listening shows you what?
State of consciousness where you right now and mantras there really is weird.
It doesn't,
it gives you a weird feeling.
Does in Mantras,
they're great because,
uh,
whatever the one is you decided to do,
it gives you a chance to focus your mind on something outside your thoughts.
Because do that.
After Yoga,
sometimes I do ohms.
Oh,
I'm to look along own session in like the Lotus position.
I'll do that.
It seems so silly and pretentious while you're doing it.
You're like,
oh,
got a fucking faggot.
I am right now.
Well,
my friends walked in on me from high school.
Like,
what are you doing?
Stupid fucking,
You would suck up a couple of Dick's after this and eat some berries.
It's not presents.
It just seems like I,
I,
it's of course it's not pretentious,
but there's a,
there's a certain amount of silliness that's attached to any yoga spirituality.
Even if you say you're a Vegan or something,
you know,
you're an environmentalist.
Anytime there's anything caring in,
in any sort of consideration,
there's like a bunch of weakness attached to it.
So if somebody catches you sitting there in the Lotus position with your,
you know,
your fuck you finger touching your thumb going,
oh,
like you silly bitch.
Do you go,
what do you,
did you go,
Oh mom,
Amari do long.
Exactly.
Oh,
that's what I do.
That's awesome.
I do long ones.
I do that sometimes in the tank to a tank gets even weirder because it
reverberates to the water.
And I do that when I need to slow my mind down and need to,
like when I get into the tank sometimes it's like as there's an adjustment
period of like a few minutes,
I'm just trying to relax and settle in and get loose.
And,
and,
and just settle into the experience.
And then sometimes I just can't,
it's just too much on my mind.
I got too much fucking going on,
too much real life TM bullshit,
you know,
invading my consciousness.
So then I go,
oh,
and I just only think about my breathing,
my breathing and making that noise.
And then it,
eventually I stopped thinking about my breathing and the breathing you just
comes automatically deep
and long.
And I just think about hitting the right note and then I'm like,
oh,
oh.
Cause there's like a certain relaxation to it when you really hit it,
when you're faking it,
when you're nervous about it,
then you're like,
uh,
you know,
there's like a break in the way you're talking.
You're not relaxed enough to let that sound come out.
What about the Buddhist?
Oh,
it has the graying of the issue,
the gray,
the shit.
That shit's insane.
Yeah.
You sound like one of those instruments.
What's it called in Australia?
The jury.
Dude,
you're fucking freaking me out.
You know what I have been chatting lately is ah,
um,
or fraught for a while now.
And I love it.
Is that [inaudible] you get rid of that one?
No.
What is that?
[inaudible] it's like this whole prayer.
Whoa.
But it's from the Tompkins and alien.
Ladies and gentlemen.
You were right.
I was wrong.
Aliens are real.
We have one here with us.
He just spoke to us in the code.
He just sent the fucking signal to the mother ships.
I know.
An embarrassing amount of prayers and other languages.
Um,
here's another,
it's not,
there's nothing embarrassing about that at all.
It's fascinating.
[inaudible] Tanya [inaudible] did that days have everything,
the gum that's in Sanskrit.
Goddamn you might be the weirdest motherfucker that's ever lived with a face.
I love you man.
I love you.
That was amazing.
I'm obviously fascinating.
If you look at this fucking Shiva over here,
I have the shit like this all over my house.
I'm fascinated by like Hindu art work.
There's just something about it to me.
You know,
when I look at,
there's something about like India and India's ancient art work.
All these women with like extra hands and shit.
It's so obviously psychedelic dude.
I ended Hensley.
I incredible dream.
Once where,
um,
it was like those things,
whatever those things were in this dream.
I was like at a restaurant though.
But these things that look like Shiva,
that,
that the,
the uh,
uh,
Angelic Hindu thing,
right?
They were,
they came up to me and they were so beautiful and so perfect and always like
looking at them and for some reason I was like,
I said,
you,
you look like me.
And they were like,
no,
you look like us is though to say like humans were a reflection of what they are
or like,
uh,
just a,
an expansion of like whatever that thing is,
you know,
another,
uh,
um,
this awesome,
you know.
And of course in Hinduism the is called Maya,
which means illusion and the way they described this universe is a,
it's like the reflection of a forest on a lake.
Our is the reflection of this,
of the true universe.
Like the true universe is so powerful that we're this kind of shimmering,
weird reflection of it.
And we all think that we're real and permanent and constant.
And it lasts forever when it's just nothing more than just like a,
I don't know,
just some kind of,
I dunno.
An illusion Maya.
That's not what they call a reality.
Illusion not real at all.
Whack is Christianity in comparison to that,
right?
Yeah.
How fascinating.
That's like such high level shit.
Yeah.
And that's like Dj high tech,
Dj eye level shit.
That's what Ninja would say.
High Level Shit.
Next level.
Shit.
You know what man?
It is next level shit,
right?
Well yeah.
I mean it's not,
I don't,
I don't know that I'd call it next level shit.
I would,
it's like high level.
It's the next level.
It's the level.
It's people zooming into the level and know what it is.
And the interesting thing about the Hindus,
they ate a lot of Hash and mushrooms and mushrooms.
Selma.
Yes.
Soma,
they don't even know exactly what it is is there's,
Soma is referenced in many of the ancient texts,
right.
And they think it might have been emoney to miscarry and psilocybe cubensis and
a bunch of other shit with mixing together.
There's a lot of debate on what it is,
but it's very clear that this something that they ate that made them have
experienced,
I mean,
they're singing,
we did psychedelics,
the,
we called it Soma.
We don't know what Soma is,
but it's very obvious from them what they wrote that it's a psychedelic plant.
There's solid,
isn't it?
Mccain.
And talks about their rig Veda and the rig Veda is hymns to Selma to that.
And they have all these ways of describing it.
And,
and that's the oldest known was have the oldest stone Leviton let know
something,
a little stone written work that,
no.
Well,
Uh,
I don't,
I'm one of the oldest.
So there's the Upanishads right there.
There's the Mahabharat,
which is what the Bhagavad Gita comes out of.
That's the one that has all the,
what are the,
is it called?
Uh,
Vimeo has,
what is it called when something flies to this guy?
Oh yeah.
I don't,
I don't remember.
I remember the name of it.
But that's a fascinating take on,
you know,
the,
all the Ufo believers believe that in that book.
Mahabharata Mahabharata Mahabharata means great India.
But Rot.
It's spelled burrata,
but Barat means India and Maha means great.
Isn't that weird how we have names for countries other than the names they use?
Like Germany is not Germany.
It's it's Douche land,
right?
Yeah.
It's not Germany.
And same with um,
uh,
like Greece.
Greece is like Hollis or something like that.
Japan is not Japan.
Nepal,
it's totally different word.
And I P p.
O.
N.
Walt's obviously in different characters,
but phonetically it's Nippon.
Nippon Wow.
Yeah.
I feel dumb now.
I wonder if Russia is a different name.
What is it now?
Yeah.
What was it before?
Naming something so weird naming like a name for any geography noise you make
with your mouth that describes a spot.
Yeah.
So fucking,
it's such an odd thing in numbers thing we're just to keeping track of,
I mean,
I guess it helps traveling.
Yeah.
Helps Gps Kinda need it going to all agree.
It's crazy that we all agree on red being stopped in green and go,
that's everywhere in the world.
Nowhere.
Nowhere that someone's stubborn.
It's like,
fuck you bitch.
I don't even like red dude though.
To get back to the India stuff.
I felt like I wanted to tell you this story,
but stop me if I already told you.
Did I ever tell you that story of like when Richard Alper gave Lsd to his guru
in India?
That story?
I think we did talk about that,
but I don't remember.
So this guy was like,
well I don't know if we talked about it on the podcast,
but I know we talked about it.
We could just kind of whatever shit overlaps this.
Um,
so Richard Alpert was this guy who,
uh,
was uh,
um,
I psychologist and he was hanging out.
Timothy leary blew his mind on acid or I think it was mushrooms and basically
the thing you were talking about happened and where he like,
cause he was really like rich at the time and he had a nice car and I think I
like things were really like,
he was like a career.
Like he was on the up so to speak.
And so he took this a psychedelic and saw us life kind of just vanish in front
of him.
And he realized that Western society,
he was obviously a bit of a sham and he ended up going to India because he'd
heard these stories of over there,
which should,
Albert is Rom dos,
right?
That's right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
He calls himself during Raam das is his name.
You can get around that star commies.
It's,
he wrote be here now.
But so he has this guru,
he goes to India and basically finds his guru is this little man and a,
and a blanket.
And Alpert has LSD with them.
And according to his story,
this little guys like you have medicine here,
you have medicine here.
And um,
Alpert gave him,
you know,
at the time,
this is acid in the 60s being carried around by like someone who was friends
with Timothy leary.
So this is high powered shit.
Albert gives him some,
he eats it,
eats one of them,
and then he liked motions for him to give him more and basically eats all of,
all of his acid,
all of it just gobbles it down.
And so a Alper,
uh,
thinks,
oh fuck,
I have a,
you know,
I've,
I've killed a little old Indian man and he's going to go insane according to
this story,
no effect.
Nothing happened,
no of Whoa,
no effect.
Oh my God.
And,
and,
and he said,
one thing he said to him was,
this reminds me of a,
uh,
this reminds me of something they had in the something valley.
Like some,
it was just,
it reminded them of something and he's like,
oh,
it's a,
it's,
it's okay.
But so Alper left,
went back to the United States mind blown by this little man because,
and he's like,
he tricked me.
He palmed the shit.
He didn't really eat.
It came back,
the guy who Albert's swears was telepathic with like,
you don't believe I ate that stuff because Albert had brought more,
he took it,
chewed it up in front of them,
shoot it up in his mouth,
open his mouth so we could see that it was in his mouth or whatever,
pill form.
And then,
uh,
after some time went under his blanket and started making moaning noises and
Alvarez like off,
fuck he does,
he aided this time when he went insane and then he came out of his blanket
laughing cause he's fucking with them and it didn't affect them again,
no effect.
He was just playing into what Albert thought it would have done now,
which was driven by somebody so enlightened and he still plays practical jokes.
Yeah.
No,
he's a funny,
I don't think humor goes away.
That's,
that's the thing.
Comedians get afraid of like spirituality or meditating or whatever cause
they're like,
I don't want to not be funny anymore,
dude.
I used to think exactly that thing.
I don't think that,
I don't think it funny goes away.
I think it just gets better.
It gets better.
The more at peace you are,
the more funny you are.
If I'm the worst I'm ever
is what?
I'm in stressful situations or upset at someone or set up myself or whatever,
you know,
when,
when you're in a good place in your happy place and no stress,
always better.
Yeah,
for sure.
I don't know,
ma'am.
It's um,
oh,
speaking of acid,
this is what I want to talk about.
The wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia.
Dude,
how awesome was that?
The craziest fucking documentary?
You know,
I,
I wasn't,
I watched it.
I had to watch it twice the first time I was too tired when I watched it and I
didn't appreciate it that much.
And then the second time I watched it and I was like way more awake and I was
under the influence of the devil's cabbage.
I tried watching it the first time.
Sober was terrible mistake or watching it barbecue.
It was like,
Whoa,
this is a fucking fascinating family,
man.
This is the nut shit I've ever seen in my life.
These fucking people,
they live in West Virginia and their whole family are criminals.
Like everyone's a criminal.
They're all pills.
Norton,
they crushed pills up.
They get pills from somewhere.
They all get prescriptions for crazy pills too.
They all got money that they get from the government and they said,
okay.
Plus,
none of them have jobs and calling West Virginia and he shakes his picks is,
hey a girl,
dude,
that's no joke either.
That's real.
It's apparently with family.
West Virginia is another one of those places where it's not so hard to get
prescription medicine.
You know,
like Florida apparently is the easiest,
you know,
that's Florida's like they have those pain management centers,
but these,
uh,
West Virginia folks there,
you know,
don't fucking drive down in Florida too and big get bags and bags of pills.
I mean,
these are all the whole family are smoking weed and snorting pills.
They're snorting pills.
This chick chick to shit out a kid.
Okay.
The kid is in the hospital,
she's in the hospital,
better pussies,
all sewn up with stitches and she's snorting pills on the side with her fucking
friend called,
I need to turn my life around.
And so the child protective services take the baby.
She's smoking cigarettes outside right after having a kid,
you know,
she smoked during the entire pregnancy.
She taking her pills,
she did everything is okay.
So you know,
she has to turn her life around.
She goes into Rehab.
It's gripping shit,
man.
Really getting is so crazy.
It,
yeah,
it's amazing.
All of them are on disability to remember that the father got 'em all into each
abilities that they don't have to work.
It's amazing,
man.
I remember when she's got pills and she's like,
I just bought these pills for eight.
I'm taking them
up the road on what's selling for $10 each.
That's called hustle bustle.
And Russell like,
what the fuck are we doing?
The country?
That's how we do it.
We make $16 fucking crazy shit,
man.
And then Hank Williams,
a third would just appear out of nowhere and start playing and
oh,
it was great.
He's friends with them.
Wow.
Yeah,
dude,
it's amazing.
They asked the mom,
they're like,
what?
What?
What do,
what do you want to happen when you die?
Oh,
when you come to my funeral,
blow pot,
smoke in the face,
and Snopes snort pills off my head.
But first on that comment on Youtube,
but first,
I forget what her exact quote is.
Imagine,
can you imagine snorting fucking oxycontin off of a corpse head?
She had this incredible quote to something like,
I don't,
you know,
at the end of it she was like,
oh,
it all my people bullshit.
But at least they know who the fuck we are.
Like this bitch is crazy.
She has committed,
they do tattoos in the middle of their fucking kitchen.
They were in a trailer and they're tattooing each other tattoo.
Not exactly sure how to spell shit.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Prison Tattoo Gun and then Jessica.
Oh,
the fucking the dancing outlaw.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Presley Manson is on his back.
That was Presley in Charles Manson tattooed on his back and he dances any
dances.
What a fucking awesome documentary.
So good.
You haven't seen yet,
Brian?
No.
Oh my God.
You've got to get on Netflix.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's Netflix.
It's Johnny Knoxville.
His company made it.
Oh really?
Yeah,
he's companies.
I guess it's a,
I remember seeing that at the beginning of a,
cause it all sounded familiar.
It was the beginning of Jack.
I said a preview for that now.
Fuck Dude.
How did I know it was amazing.
It was amazing.
Credible.
Completely believable.
Fuck yeah.
It's real,
man.
They're crying and shit and there's,
everything's fine.
Yeah,
I don't think so,
man.
They followed these people around for a year and this is all the shit that got.
Can I please show you something?
A video.
Can I show you an Internet video?
Totally.
Maybe I will.
I have a video.
I don't need to show you guys a video,
but I'm gonna talk about it while I'm ducking looks for this.
When I was in Germany,
there was a station that had a 24 hour camera that was on the pilgrimage at
Mecca.
Cool.
And for 24 hours a day,
it just showed these people putting on these white robes and moving around this
square.
What does that square man,
what is the deal with that?
It's called,
isn't it called the now that hodge now,
that's the whole thing I think is called the Hodgetts caught the Hodges like a
pilgrimage.
Pilgrimage.
Well,
anyway,
this thing is,
this does big box that's in the center of the square and there's like,
it's really beautiful,
like incredible architecture.
I mean,
it's fucking amazing and everyone's super well behaved,
you know?
There's no one getting arguments or anything
and they're all like in close proximity to each other and they're touching each
other and they're walking around in a circle around this box 24 hours a day.
I watched it for an hour and a half to sit in there with my jaw open like wow,
fuck.
And it Dunkin had sent me this video once of 'em,
I sent him a video of a ants or we both had seen it rather of ants in a death
spiral,
maybe weed.
What was the reason for it?
Like the one of the Queen had died and he tweeted it and it's this.
Yeah,
no.
The reason is is because like ants follow each other's trail and so basically
they end up following a trail and they're wrong.
They're basically just end up going in a circle following the same trail.
How does that happen?
Because I want to add fucks.
It fucks up or the queen fucks up or something.
And so they followed it.
So you get the entire nest of ants all going in this circle that looks like this
beautiful spiral.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
And it's available online.
It's called the the ant death spiral spiral is what it's is.
Cause they all just sent me this video of them doing that at Mecca.
It was like almost the exact same thing.
Yeah,
it looks exactly the same except they don't die.
But this,
this,
this desire to go run in a circle.
They're not just walking up that thing and touching it.
They're walking around it and they're walking around.
It just covered in robes.
I mean they're basically dressed like they were dressed thousands of years ago.
Well they're actually,
there was just a video on CNN if this guy went there with like those with that,
what is it called?
The things edits had those weird silver like disks.
They used to record stuff or like cone things.
I can't remember.
Anyway,
it's like this thing from like a very long time ago of Mecca with the recording
from back then showing like the city around it and stuff and it was just much
more dilapidated and less built up at the same fucking thing.
Man.
All of them Muslims going around that.
It's an an amazing that they've committed to that for so long.
I mean,
that's a fascinating thing.
When I was watching that,
I was like,
if this,
this is thousands of years old,
right?
Islam is over a thousand years old,
So 1500 1500 years old,
something like that.
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know,
do it.
Whatever it is,
it's very old.
Okay.
If this had happened now,
if this was a new thing,
if we were watching a new thing and there was a channel on television that was
dedicated 24 hours to these new people that wear robes and walk around in a
circle where there's a sacred box cause they have to come to from all over the
fucking world and they just spend hours and hours walk around the circle to this
box,
we would shut that fucking thing down so quick.
There would be armed fucking men outside with tanks and jet's ready to drop
bombs.
It'd be like,
what the fuck is in the box?
You freaks.
What do you got a time machine in their stupid,
what the fuck you,
you're dressing like you dressed a thousand years ago and you're touching the
box.
Is this fucking thing going to take you back to a thousand years ago?
Tell me why you dressed like a prey to it.
Don't forget that they bow to it constantly and they always know where it is.
Yup.
And they touch it,
they move around,
they want to touch it and people like pile through and eventually get to the
center and touch it.
They're all touching it,
a whole around it and around the people touching it.
It's just layer upon layer upon layer upon layer of people.
Thousands and thousands.
I don't know how many thousands just moving around in a circle milling around
this thing.
It's um,
it's really,
it's,
it's really easy to go to it,
man.
I'd like to see which is fascinating that how,
this is what I wanted to bring up.
Like how does that happen?
How does a meme,
how does an idea become so powerful that all of these people,
like a billion of them all over the world?
I mean,
what is the numbers of Islam?
Is it a billion?
Something like that?
I have no idea.
Probably at least,
right?
Yeah,
I dunno.
But I mean,
let's say it's not,
whatever it is,
giant numbers of humans all around the world all follow this one pattern and
they really do all want to make this pilgrimage to Mecca and they really do say
it's an incredible spiritual awakening like the symbolizes so much to them that
even if it's a placebo effect going there and being in the presence of this
thing and touching it and being around all these people that are like,
oh my God,
I'm at Mecca,
we're at Meca today.
And it forces everyone to be wholly forces everyone to try to like follow the
tenants of this religion and really believe in the love that this,
this group brings everybody together.
This is,
their religion is so much more power than it full than anybody else's.
Nobody else is willing to make that sort of commitment.
So because of this intense bond,
this intense commitment they have,
this is one of the things that makes them the most dangerous job.
They pray three times a day.
I don't know.
I don't know how many times I pray whatever happened to that kid that everyone
thought was like this born again.
God,
they just like lived next to a tree,
remember?
And they were like,
he would just sit there quiet quietly for days and night eat and everyone was
living in a tree that was in India.
I wasn't,
yeah,
I remember having a kid is in the United Indian,
I don't know where,
I think it was India.
Yeah,
I don't know for sure,
but I remember that I was crazy.
And then he went up into the woods,
he's getting all this attention and he said he needed to go where it's quieter
because he was trying to like do some intense thing and he was even,
see,
I don't remember the exact words he said,
but he's like,
I am not Buddha,
but I am the uh,
some sort of incarnation of the something,
something.
It was really weird,
creepy.
And then he just kind of disappeared.
Maybe it was just crazy kid in India.
Maybe he's just over there eating mushrooms,
talking shit,
living in the woods.
And then when people come around to interview and he just touched,
he's so high,
he doesn't even know what he's saying.
He's talking about.
He's the incarnation of the Buddha.
And the [inaudible] sent me some shit.
Awesome fucking professor in college and he got me,
he basically talked me into going to India.
I went to India for several weeks because of him.
Wow.
Cause I took a course called introduction to Southeast Asia of it.
He said in India,
what happens is hundred,
200 years ago,
a holy man,
someone,
someone considers a guru,
drops the glove or does some little thing or eats and Mellon next to some
certain place and throws it down.
And then it's followed.
Followers were like,
oh,
let's uh,
enshrine this place where the seed from the Mellon,
our master rate is.
And then at temple eventually springs up around that.
And so they've got NDAs just scattered with like shrines and temples and all
these bizarre like constructs that come from,
you know,
very specific events in the Zyl because Hinduism isn't just like one religion,
one religion.
It's a fragmentation of all these different ideas.
People who worship Braum and people who worship Vishnu,
people who worship Shiva,
people who worship Demigodz David,
it's all kinds of shit.
It's not one thing.
It's like a fragmentation of a,
of something.
They make the coolest art dude.
Yeah,
you do.
They're fucking Shiva.
Like the Shiva that is,
you know,
someone explained to me that this is supposed to be the god of cannabis,
that this is supposed to be the got to cannabis and see that little thing that
he's standing on the bottom.
Yeah.
That's supposed to be ignorance.
Alright.
Right.
That's why he's got a sack that he carries.
That's his wheat.
It's wheat and this is all represents fire and he's standing over ignorance.
You would think the backer dollar bill,
you would think ignorance would be way bigger.
That's a little baby ignorance,
I should say.
Very optimistic.
Speaking ignorance.
Can I show you this?
Yeah.
What is it?
What is this?
What?
Explain what we're watching.
I'm not really sure.
It's some sort of patriotic musical.
It's called,
that's America to me.
Look it up on Youtube.
Okay,
so
can you see it?
Okay?
Yeah.
What
was going on,
dude.
Mom and dad and Apple Pie.
Baseball Games at pig Nixon.
July is a real,
oh my God.
You go see this guy by the man sing the song.
Looks like Don Frye fucked the kid with down syndrome.
Eh?
Oh my goodness.
That's America too.
I want to talk to that dude about the universe.
Wow.
Oh Man.
Willie,
Danny.
Just to help her fellow man
again,
defensive,
right not of gray to give her all the time.
Oh my God.
That through karate kicks this.
This is the most insane thing I've ever seen in my life.
These people for the iTunes folks,
I'm very sorry.
These people wearing stars and stripes shirts and they're standing in front of a
big stars.
He's tribes thing that says America
saying,
this is straight and sanity.
It's insane.
I've never seen anything like it.
These people probably can't wait for this song to answer.
They can just go fuck each other.
I bet they just snort math and fuck the shit out of each other and then they get
mad.
They're so repressed.
Oh Jesus.
I can't believe I did that.
Jesus.
Why?
We'll have the devil tell me,
well,
this is the last time he was the last time,
and then they just meet with the same thing bad.
Did he just get brain surgery?
It's like get each other pregnant.
Shit,
loads of each other.
Make new retards.
This is all what we're talking about,
man.
This should happen to the Greeks,
to the Romans.
It happened to everybody.
Eventually the fucking tribe gets watered down to the point where there's so
many of these fuckheads that people want to pay attention to them and even want
to elect one of their own to be the king of the world.
You know people like that.
Look at that.
Look at the size of that audience,
man.
There were thousands of people this last time.
You had a thousand people for your fucking show.
It's been a long time.
This is ridiculous.
Man,
you need to work that church angle shit,
a lot of money in that search son.
You don't even have to write good comedy.
Just throws him Jesus in there and hall and say,
Gosh,
and Golly,
and don't ever swear Baldwin.
That shit.
Even like Terence Mckenna and his lectures,
he could throw a lob,
some softballs
or Deepak Chopra or anytime you listen to any of those guys,
you have to be a dummy not to see the game.
And if you're all crazy,
that's America.
That's America,
raw rock gods,
gun government.
There's nothing wrong with God.
There's nothing wrong with government and there's nothing wrong with having
guns,
but you get all three of them together and they creates this weird fucking
hybrid mentality.
That's America.
We don't have to think too much.
You don't have to think about the fact you're getting fucked by gangsters.
Yeah,
it's,
but it's that sets the sappiness.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not recognizing what the fuck is really going on when everybody's all God,
guns and government.
Like that's all well and good.
If there was a real bad guy and if it was a real situation where we didn't do
anything wrong,
but when you're one,
the countries run by fucking gangsters,
when you just assume some gangster shit is going down.
Dick Cheney was the fucking CEO of Halliburton before he gets into office,
gets into office is basically one and Shit,
right?
And all of a sudden how Britain gets billion dollars of no bid contracts to fix
up Iraq because we just decided to drop fucking bombs on them and he profits off
of it.
He has Halliburton stock and if that's black gangster,
what the fuck is nobody does anything.
All right?
We say in my act he shot his friend and his face and his friend apologize.
That's as gangster as you get.
That's gangster shit.
That's an Al Capone Shit.
These fucking people started a war and made money off it and everyone's like,
well,
think about the idea of it.
We got a problem.
We're going to just,
it would,
if you know if Halliburton,
first of all,
there's something like $90 billion that's missing.
You know there's like some insane amount of money that's missing.
I think about of Halliburton was a one person.
It was one person and they stole $90 billion.
You can't just do that to be like where's the fucking money?
But because it's a gigantic corporation it's like,
Oh what happened?
There's paperwork and who knows?
We're going to see if we can find it.
It's probably around here somewhere.
I mean that's,
that's some fucking straight gangster show.
Like what I like is like,
cause we can talk about it like this and nothing's probably gonna happen to us.
Like no one's going to get ICO will be okay.
But I like watching when someone in Russia who she's no here,
when someone pokes the dragon and not wearing tries to snap like that Wiki leaks
guy,
you know what I mean?
We're going to try to put that rape charge on him.
Rape charge
and you watch him.
He went,
cause I saw this awesome lecture with him as he was just starting to to do it.
And you got all this life and I'm and this energy and he's like seemed like a
hero.
And then you cut to like four months later.
He looks like a ghost.
He's tired.
He's like beat down because they're just applying the CIA pressure.
He can't be with a girl if he meets a girl in the back of his head.
He's got to think it's this girl really liked me or is this an operative who got
sent in to shit too?
That's really cool.
They did it.
A rape charge on that guy that happened to coincide with him releasing the
biggest military leak and the United States history.
They're so transparent.
That's like the most transparent should ever,
unless he's really raped.
Somebody was like,
nobody believed me.
They didn't have such a good guy.
No,
he,
I caught,
I mean,
come on,
really fuck knows.
I don't know the guy,
but also they'd be weird if he was like a really good guy in some ways.
What a Douche bag in other ways.
Well I,
I'm sure it's a possibility.
I don't know him.
That's a problem.
I think that the,
there's a better chance that they're trying to frame it much better to send a
pdf out that was encrypted or something,
something like that.
And if he vanishes or something weird atmosphere and then he's sending the
password out that I don't think it would change much.
I think people would go,
wow,
somebody killed him.
Oh well what's Paula Abdul doing that crazy bitch.
She's driving drunk again.
Huh?
People would find some abstraction.
We don't do anything.
That's what's so fucking weird about our [inaudible].
We are going to do everything or anything is if we change and the only way we
are going to change as if the introduction of new ideas gets to the people at
the top.
If the people at the very top of the food chain that are doing the most fucked
up things in the world and we got to get them to have a look at this,
we've got to get them to realize you're fucking,
you're creating this gigantic volcano of shit energy and it's not necessarily,
you don't have to do it this way.
Everybody could figure out some way to make this thing work a lot better.
Just take this shit down.
We're going to turn the lights out.
That's right.
Can you about an hour and 20 minutes.
I'm gonna come back in and we're going to have a conversation.
He sound like,
what's his name from I dream of Jeannie.
Duh Duh,
Duh.
What's his name?
Face captain.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
The lead and I dream of Jeannie.
What's that actor's name?
Someone's got to know that he took,
but there's poorly thought out theory theory of giving.
Um,
that's what he says.
There's a joy bay hard interview with him where she spray said that they should
give drugs to posters.
He's the,
I don't know,
I can't remember the name of it now.
He's like,
he was Jr.
Who is that?
There's a whole layer jr from Dallas,
right?
The fuck is his name.
I can't fucking remember now.
He's an interesting dude.
He's got one of those greenhouses.
He's off the grid.
He's off the grid and then so joy bay is interviewing him and it's a nice
interview and everything's going fine.
Then she ambushes and like,
so I,
I hear that you took LSD.
What was that like for the quick flash?
He looks at her like,
you fucking bitch.
We are doing at normal interview now you're trying to corner me.
And he's like,
uh.
He's like,
well,
it took away my fear of death.
Whoa.
Yeah,
it was really cool.
He talked
about politicians should have to take LSD.
What do you think that he definitely knew that she was going to do that and he
seemed so authentically surprise,
like you know the micro gesture where for a second I was like,
Oh,
oh really?
You think so?
Look it up.
I mean,
you can look it up right now.
It's on youtube.
It's,
what does the name Larry Hagman Ebay.
Our interviews.
Larry Hagman LSD is like taking over man.
She's doing all this crazy items.
Did you see her?
She walked off the set because they had bill O'Reilly on the bill.
O'Reilly was talking nonsense.
So she walked off the set.
Okay.
I heard about that.
I didn't see it,
but I heard about that.
It was pretty interesting.
Was that with Whoopi Goldberg?
Yeah.
They both walked off.
They staged a protest.
I said,
enough.
We've had enough.
Like they didn't know what he was going to say.
They'd been planning that thing for days.
Do you think they didn't know?
I mean,
maybe they're just too busy to pay attention.
Maybe it's so much shit going on.
They don't have the time.
We'll probably both on an arrow.
Riley's going to get on there and say it sounds in concern.
Yeah.
He was lobbing some softballs at George Bush was watching them interview George
Bush and one of the things that he said,
you know,
I had Barney frank on and I called them all,
I'll a liar and a coward
like he's bragging to George Bush that he called Barney Frank.
A Liar and a coward.
Yeah.
Bushes.
Like,
wow,
you really showed them I killed a million Iraqis.
Yeah,
million bitch.
I publicly admitted to a war crime and no one's going to do
when they're in the uncommercial.
He just leans over
bill.
Bill Buck.
Marsha,
I killed a million motherfuckers.
I don't want to hear your Faggot,
faggot.
Talk about you told about gay congressmen that he's a coward.
Shut the fuck up.
You big giant bitch at big seven foot tall bitch.
I made reverse around with
you.
Really think okay.
Okay.
You're a good guy.
You're good.
Yeah you're a good guy.
Cause imma grab above the knee grab that are very sexual almost as long as they
ought to go too high they can get away with it.
But basically this is sexual triggers above your knee.
You know a men will grab your fucking knee.
That's like you're,
you're,
you're close to pulling my dick out right there.
What are you doing up at George Bush is a knee grabbing motherfucker.
Nobody knows how to intimidate the shit out of him that he grabs me.
He's like we'll have you up at the groves.
Bohemian Grove.
You think holy Shit.
You think it's real man.
You'll see modeling
crop circles,
Bro.
Crop circles.
That was so disappointing when they like came out and showed how easy it was to
make those things what
they did and really they did in a lot of the designs,
but there's a lot of zines that are very questionable.
I would like to see how they did it because some of them are incredibly complex
there.
Fractals there,
they're amazingly precise and they're huge and they appear so quickly.
I'm not inclined to believe that all of them they're done by the same people.
I think it's very possible that some of them had done is by some new crazy
technology that we have maybe in satellite form.
I mean think about a lot of them,
you know appeared in the past but they weren't not intricate.
Like there's a,
this is a thing about them from like the 16 hundreds I believe it might've even
been slightly earlier than that,
but a drawing of a devil do it with a sickle,
making a crop circle and a lot of the crop circle people,
they look at that as evidence,
but there was never anything like they see today.
Like there are far more complex like the Mandelbaum Nemanda brought set the
fractal,
you know,
there's like this infinite beautiful fractal.
When they figured it out mathematically on a computer within like weeks,
someone had drawn it in a crop circle.
So it's like,
to me it's like,
you know,
there's an,
oh,
it's either alien saying,
oh you get it,
or it's some fucking really funny,
you know,
government scientists with this crazy ability to transform matter or plants on
the ground with this laser beam,
they can make a design in the wheat.
I mean that's much more likely that it's some sort of a weapon or not even a
weapon.
Or maybe it was something that was developed as they were developing weapons and
then you,
they realize that you could make,
it was such a powerful pulsating move.
You know,
there's this beam that you can make designs in the grass with it.
I mean,
it's very possible you think about all the shit that they have that we didn't
know about for the longest time.
Stealth bombers and shit.
And who knows what the fuck they're working on an area 51 they could have
somebody at the top of the heap or it's a local college and then all the art
students at every year have to do like three of them per class.
And it's like this big school secret.
Well those mother fuckers deserve some money.
They should be coming out and bragging about it.
I mean,
just the circle makers.
There's a guy,
a bunch of guys called the circle maker,
[inaudible] dot org and they,
they've made a bunch of them and they've shown they're,
they're pretty good.
I mean,
no,
no doubt about it.
But the ones that are there,
the other ones that people have now,
this is all shit that I've read on the Internet and watching documentary,
so I'm not exactly sure if it's the same over.
It's true rather,
but what the way they describe these stocks being bent,
it's like they have these growth nodes where it explodes like almost like it's
been microwaved,
like it expands out from heat and then blows up where it bends over and at these
exist all throughout these patterns and those patterns,
they don't really exist like that during a just stomping them down with boards.
So it may,
it may very well be that there's a bunch of different ways that people have done
these things.
The one thing I thought when I was trying to believe in crop circles as well,
if there was a super intelligent thing sending signals through space,
then maybe they'd figured out that part of evolution is that whatever the
species was would learn to plant crops or something.
And so they're trying to communicate through the food stamp,
the food source.
So that totally makes sense.
I mean that's,
you're guaranteeing that people are gonna see it,
especially if they can't really see us.
What if their vision and their need for vision is so entirely different than us,
that they literally can't see us,
but they know where plants are and they're,
they're like not even in this dimension.
And they're communicating through some sort of a portal.
And the way they can communicate through this portal is by implanting these
designs onto what they know is going to be food because they know that,
oh,
we've received a certain signal from this area that indicates that it's plant
life and uh,
it's grown in large areas that seem to be uniform,
which indicate that someone is growing it on purpose.
So it must be their food.
So let's just leave designs in this food.
That's it.
It could be,
but it also could be some fucking dude.
Your boards,
some of them are amazing
though.
I believe that some of them could be,
but some of them are for sure.
It's things like that though.
Like if you look at any artists doing something and he didn't know an artist did
that,
like if you go out in the middle of a pyramid and some artists worked on it,
you know overnight with you know,
making this masterpiece and you,
you just didn't think it would be like anyone had access to this pyramid and you
just saw it,
you would probably think,
wow,
how the fuck was this made,
you know?
To me I look at a lot of these things and to me it looks like,
okay this is something like a bunch of people plan the shit out and they just
fucking,
it's like graffiti almost and there's towns that they're always found in there
like poor towns that their only income is people going to see these things.
Stuff like that.
Yeah.
Like in England,
the crop circle,
but it is a good point,
right?
Yeah.
If you set up like roadside signs and sell lemonade,
you get a fucking minute,
you'll clean it up.
Yeah.
There's what that will mean.
That was an issue that I had about the whole Ufo experience too.
I'm like,
the,
the problem I have with believing you fos is that people are selling books and
people are making money and when you start making money and you're an author,
like I was making fun of,
um,
what's the guy's name that wrote communion?
Whitley Strieber.
Yeah.
He's like the premier guys.
He's been abducted by aliens.
Also happens to be a fucking brilliant fiction writer.
Wrote Wolfen you wrote that?
The Werewolf Movie Wolfen which has got one of the fucking coolest werewolf
movies ever.
They weren't really werewolf.
They were just super intelligent wolves and it was the fucking main star in that
movie.
I haven't seen that.
Goddamn that movies are good.
I'm buying that shit on iTunes today.
Bitch.
Too thin.
They better have that.
I bet they don't,
man.
You know,
iTunes is just getting the Beatles now,
finally.
So all I remember that thing.
What is the guy's name?
Who's the main star right around when the howling came out,
didn't it think it was even a little bit Werewolf too?
That's my shit.
That's another fucking subject we'd beat to death on this podcast.
Werewolves,
Bro.
Where?
Whoops.
No,
they don't have it.
Of course.
Not fucking clowns go.
Have you been checking Amazon lately?
I've noticed every time I buy a CD now I just go to Amazon first because,
uh,
it's like iTunes.
There was something that the other day,
White Buffalo,
which is a local la guy that's really good.
I went on a iTunes,
it was like 1299 then went on Amazon.
It was eight 99 and it was Albert Finney thing to,
Oh,
this is DVD 2002.
That's not when the movie came out pitch.
That's when the DVD was released to Wolfen Whitley Strieber paperback.
Wow.
They can you still buy a VHS and credible.
I wonder when the movie came out though.
I know the DVD came out in [inaudible] 81 bro.
I was a freshman in high school.
This movie was the shit to day one click.
Please
give me that shit.
He seen the,
uh,
Amandil Bulb.
If you seen the three d projections I have of the Mandelbrot set fractal.
Yeah.
Fractals are insane.
The idea behind fractals is,
I mean that's,
that's really probably the fact of the universe.
The fabric of everything is that it is infinitely small and infinitely large and
it goes to no end.
That just keep going and going and going and it never stops.
It's,
there's never
a smallest point ever.
Right.
I don't think we could wrap our heads around that.
You know,
we think that,
well,
there's should be,
you know,
and you know,
everything gets smaller and smaller.
Well,
there has to be some infinite small point.
No,
no,
no.
It just,
it's almost like a line of code,
like just goes into another line like it is it,
that's how we are connected,
like dimension to dimension.
It just gets infinitely small and then expands out again.
That's intense.
You want to intense,
there's a big controversy right now because a Obama's book,
Obama has a kid's book and a,
in this kid's book he fucking talks about how great sitting bull is.
Sitting bowl is.
He says a medicine man who healed broken hearts and broken promises.
It's a fine,
it is fine that we are different.
The book,
who's royalties go to helping the children falling or disabled service members
also says that the Lakota chief spoke out and led his people against many
policies of the United States government.
He is most famous for his stunning victory in 1876 over lieutenant colonel
George Armstrong cuts Custer in the battle of little big horn.
So basically he's got a fucking,
he's the president of a nation and he's praising a guy taking a side on,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
native American that killed a bunch of American citizens.
Like what is that all about?
That's a weird choice.
Cause I understand that you think that war is bad.
And I understand that you think that imperialism and everything that got us here
and created earth are created,
uh,
the America rather earth it's been fulfilled,
was referring to this was raw.
I understand that you would think that that's,
you know,
that it's a wrong thing that happened.
It's terrible that happened.
But you know what a weird choice to to,
you know,
obviously that we won and that's what happened.
And that's why people are here.
And that's where the cities,
so you're a part of this,
that one.
So you're,
I guess what you're saying is we want in a terrible way,
and we took over the,
the Indians in a terrible way and thank goodness that they got some licks in and
let's,
let's give him props and you know,
you gig does kicked our ass a little bit more and like bring them back into the
fold and say like,
okay,
well this is a man that had a lot of value to his people and our people weren't
exactly fucked up,
but let's put bygones be bygones and let's talk about what a bad ass this dude
was.
I mean,
they had like bows and arrows and they were fresh new divorces.
You know what I mean?
Like they only had horses flagging a hundred years or so and they,
they kicked ass on custard with his guns.
You know,
I mean they had some guns back then too,
but you know,
they,
they fucking trapped the American citizens.
They fucking sucked him into a trap.
Well,
I could see out like a black president would be dirty coal,
but it's an interesting choice.
Right.
Well I get it though,
cause it's like,
I mean,
it wasn't that long ago that the United States government was like with
enslaving his ancestors.
So it totally makes sense that you'd idolize it,
but they don't ever say that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he never comes out and fully expresses himself and he never comes out and
says,
this is what's important to me about this.
I understand that this man killed American citizens.
And I understand that,
you know,
if it wasn't for battles like this,
we would still have problems with Indians attacking us and we could never have
the same life that we have now.
I mean,
somebody had to pave the way supposedly to do this.
I understand that he would say that,
but you've got to,
you've got to,
in my opinion,
at least,
you got to kind of explain where your head's at with all this just right.
You can't just show tweet and he's following you.
Yeah.
But you can't just say,
you know that he,
you know,
was a,
he's most famous for his stunning victory in 1876 which you got to say is we
have to get past all of this stuff and recognize that even though,
uh,
America was evil or we did something that we shouldn't have done or you know,
we,
we took over their land and fuck them over and written.
Let's all let that shit go.
Okay.
What's not me?
And it's not you.
It's our ancestors.
We have learned from this and we are stronger because of this.
But what people don't like to hear is the Lakota,
you know that name Lakota.
That's what they call themselves.
Well,
you know what the Indians called them sue,
because sue means enemy.
Cause the LAKOTAS would just run around Jack and folks.
Okay.
That's what they did.
Indians did the same thing that we did.
They just did it on shitty smaller scale.
The Sun ritual,
you know the sandwich,
what's it called?
What's that car?
There's not the Senate.
It's hard.
I'm like the fuck is that card they put hooks in your chest from,
was that movie?
Um,
the fucking,
what's his name?
God.
Sundance.
It's called the center.
Like the Sundance festival is named after.
It was cause it really?
Yeah,
the Sundance and what it is is,
oh it was when you go,
oh man called horse.
Yeah,
man called horse.
And it was an initiative,
initiatory phase where they were to hang themselves from trees or from something
with hooks through their chest and just hang there where their skin kind of
being pulled out.
What was the reason for that?
I think it was a initiation thing,
I guess.
I have no idea.
I assume it's like something,
there's something to that.
I think there's something to initiations.
I think there's something to grand events like this hodge,
like the pilgrimage to Mecca.
I think there is something to that man.
And I think that might be one of the reasons why people are fucked up cause we
don't have very clearly defined moments.
We have to get your shit together.
You are a man now.
This is it.
Move on.
Bam.
You,
you know you hit the next stage.
Let's acknowledge the fact all together that we are evolving together.
We have reached this new plateau.
Father have gone to the mountain,
you know you're going to do some shit.
Put your hands in the gloves,
the hands and the gloves with the bullet ants and get fucked up.
You know,
get past your pain figures.
I think that's what I said earlier man,
about the Greeks and the Romans.
I think people get soft as fuck.
That's what's happening.
You dirty,
dirty bitches.
Richard Harris,
a man called horse.
Let me see while I one click that shit son Love Amazon one click for movies.
It's the most addictive thing of all time.
I had a professor who is really into the Lakota and I asked fascinating,
asked him if he'd have you ever done a Sundance and he was like that is an
inappropriate question.
What a bitch.
Fuck you.
Informations inappropriate.
Maybe shouldn't be a fucking professor.
Kind of shocking to me that you can't tell me if you,
if you'd done that or like I'm supposed to know the etiquette of Villa Cota.
What a,
we gave me that.
I never learned that.
You're not supposed to ask someone if they did a Sundance.
What is that?
You're not supposed to ask?
He said that's an inappropriate,
that's educational dramas that,
what's that?
That's educational
drama.
That's drama.
You know what it was?
He didn't have the stones for it and he didn't want to admit it.
That's what it is.
He knows what he think he was loke stir shit.
Yeah.
Well maybe he wants you to think that he did it.
Maybe he's like one of those dudes who pretends as a black belt and really is
only taking karate a couple of times.
My hands are be registered lethal weapons.
You know?
It might've been one of those things you just didn't want to let you know that.
No,
of course I didn't do that.
That's for psychos.
He wanted to let you think.
Maybe this Indian kinds of psycho made me feel like a fucking asshole though,
man.
I was like,
Oh,
why did I ask him about it?
Cause he's a douchebag and he's a douchebag.
Period.
If he didn't recognize that,
if he honestly got offended about something that you were completely and utterly
ignorant about,
that means that obviously he's a dummy.
He's a either a dummy or a douchebag.
You're take your pick.
You know,
you can't recognize it.
People don't recognize that this is a,
a nutty thing to talk about.
You know,
we don't recognize that it's something sacred to you.
W D fucking hooks through your nipples and get suspended for the air.
I can't ask you that cause it's kind of silly.
All right.
Inappropriate.
Inappropriate question.
Why did you ask why?
And I didn't feel like she didn't walk away.
That guy should be fired.
You put your clothes back on and left in it.
You don't condition be someone next to him going,
all right dude,
chill the fuck out.
Don't talk like that.
That's dump.
You can go back to teaching in class,
but we have to let you know.
This is real life rules.
The ideal to ask a professor or anything?
Sure.
Especially I smoked weed with him of my professors.
Awesome.
Right before class.
And he even had like the fucking spray stuff.
Uh,
so you won't smell like weed.
That's smart.
Smart professor.
He took a chance with use on,
there was that professor at my college who is an anthropologist that,
uh,
study tech it out like mushrooms.
Whoa.
And he was a Fulbright scholar and he said that missionaries came to,
I can't remember where it was,
maybe it was South America,
Mexico.
They came to this place in Mexico with all these new bibles that were translated
into,
um,
that were translated into their language and no one would touch the Bible's.
Everyone's avoiding the bibles and they wouldn't touch the bibles.
And uh,
they are,
the missionaries were like,
why aren't they touching these bible?
It's,
the reason is,
is because they had the,
translated the Bible into the word of God,
which translated,
which was the,
uh,
these people's,
name for mushrooms.
The word of God was what they called mushrooms in their language.
It translated into a word of God.
And so the reason they didn't want to touch the bibles is because if they ate
mushrooms,
they couldn't have sex for like five days before and you weren't supposed to eat
meat and there was a purification process and they were looking at the Bible's
thing.
Oh No,
we can't do that because it means we have to it like we haven't gone through the
steps that we do when we eat my shrimp.
So no sex for five days.
I don't remember the specifics.
I think there was a purification they had to go undergo before they tripped out.
Dude,
I think there's,
there's place in this world for ritual.
There's something that we get some sort of comfort from ritual,
you know,
even if it's just a ritual of going to Disneyland every year,
there's something comforting about it.
When I was a kid,
I used to think that,
uh,
you know,
holidays and shit,
we're fucked.
The holidays,
he gives a fuck about Christmas.
But it was a really,
mostly because my childhood was kind of disappointing,
you know,
it wasn't because there's something wrong with rituals.
I was rebelling against something that wasn't fun for me,
you know,
not a,
not non fun environment growing up.
But I think for,
for most people like significations like that where this is,
you are a man now and you are,
you know,
you have reached a,
a point of wisdom,
you know,
where,
especially when they would actually have to work for it.
Like say what you want about,
you know,
someone reaching,
uh,
go into confirmation classes to get confirmed as a,
you know,
a Christian or a Catholic rather or you know,
what you have to do to,
you know,
be a,
a man in the Jewish religion and read the towel mud and all the shit that
already had to go through.
That stuff makes them work.
It makes them work towards something and it makes them at least believed that at
the end of the goal they have created something.
There's something different now they've accomplished something.
They've passed into the next thing.
There's probably room for that.
That might be why we're all fucking lost.
You know,
we don't have these like moments of,
of things happening.
So unless you do something difficult and then learn from it.
I get,
I'll get any growth.
You know,
you just get stagnant like we're were designed shitty.
Well,
and now what about that?
There's like an odd thing where you're not allowed to design new rituals.
If you're going to go buy a ritual,
you have to go by the Catholic ritual or wet,
but why can't you come up with a new ritual?
I can't.
You come up with some news too dangerous because the,
the reason why people want to lead people always is because they want money and
pussy.
All right?
That's what it is.
That's the copters ethic.
That's really what they're looking for.
Conquer Atha.
So you see like,
you know,
Waco,
what happens in Waco,
dudes playing guitar,
fucking everyone's wife and he's got guns everywhere.
That's what happens.
That's the reality of,
of beginning religion.
It's most of the time the people that want true enlightenment don't want to
lead.
They just want to find it all.
They want to be comfortable and happy.
They went everywhere,
but they don't want to be the man.
You know,
once you want to be the man and you're fucking singing songs and you sit around
the campfire talking about how we can create our own world shit,
man,
you're,
you're thinking about pussy and money.
That's what you're doing,
dude.
And it just confuses the fucking message.
Right?
That's the fucking thing.
That's a confusing thing.
I read this essay by um,
fuck,
what's his name?
Uh,
Alistair Crowley.
And he was talking about the grail and he's like the thing,
that paradox of the grail,
which is like the thing that gives you a terminal life,
but what he was talking about enlightenment is that the moment you get it,
you can never enjoy it.
You can't want it.
You can't write it.
The wanting of the thing pushes it away.
It only,
and by the time you do receive all the material benefits that it gives you,
it doesn't matter to you anymore anyway.
Don't you feel like that's the same thing with comedy?
Yeah.
You think that is?
If you're looking for comedy,
if you're trying to make,
get someone to laugh.
It's a weird paradox where it's not about the trying,
it's about just a tuning in and letting it all happen.
It's the same with everything like that is,
that's the way to do life,
right?
That's a way to do life outside the ego.
That's the thing that I,
everything as far as comedy goes,
everything for me fucks up when I start caring about it in the wrong way.
Yeah.
And I thinking about it under the wrong eyes,
like trying to impress people or trying to,
you know,
make something.
It's,
you know,
it's not just an just it dishonest,
just launched is the best word.
Not In tune.
It's not real.
You're just,
you know,
and there's comics,
there's like certain comic that a friend of mine just work with recently.
I don't want to mention any names,
but a buddy of mine,
he middled for this guy and the guy just ate shit every night.
And he was saying how embarrassing it was that this guy is just,
he's,
his act just wasn't connecting.
It was like,
it felt artificial,
you know,
and that's what happens to some guys.
They lose their connection with whatever it is that allows you to create
creative things in the first place and then all of sudden it becomes something,
something fake and something that you don't,
you don't know what it is and you're using it because it's worked before,
but it's just like,
you know,
it's,
it doesn't mean anything to you anymore because you lost the fucking trail.
There's the ants and the spot.
Yeah.
You're in that fucking spiraling.
He can't get out.
And you can,
I mean,
you can do that your whole life.
If you don't get slapped back end.
How do you slap someone back and you can't write,
they have to slap themselves in.
No,
I think you can slap somebody back in,
but you've got to be,
they have to really respect to you and you have to want us change too.
But it definitely can be done.
And there's different versions of it,
but it's like,
I mean,
that's what a free,
ideally what a friend does.
It seems to me that it's all a mathematical pattern.
It seems to me that from the time the Greeks were around to the Romans and it
goes through,
you know,
the Egyptians and the Mayans and every civilization does this.
Every civilization gets to a point where people are just soft and fucking stupid
and then shit hits the fan.
Yeah,
that's it.
You know,
and it starts again.
And then we leave the,
the,
the rotting husks of the society left behind us as we a new one somewhere else.
What a great way to end the podcast.
This is,
by the way,
folks,
this is all nonsense and we are in no way scholars,
but Dunkin's more educated than I.
Uh,
I,
uh,
yeah.
I only spent three years at Umass Boston and only because I didn't want people
to think of when I was a loser and barely paid attention and was getting D's in
my last year when I decided to stop going,
I was literally completely board,
had no idea what I was doing with my life.
I was doing.
It was like doing martial arts tournaments and I was doing this so that I could
answer it to people and tell them,
oh,
I'm going to Umass.
But you read a lot.
I mean,
the whole thing,
if you're reading a lot,
that's all the shit that I was reading when I was in college is nothing like the
shit that I'm reading now.
Much smaller.
It's much more complex and interesting now,
but that Shit's more available,
you know.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
thank you for tuning in.
Duncan Trussell,
T R U S S e l l at Twitter.
Bitch is thank you to the pod.
Clap the to the fleshlight rather for sponsoring the podcast.
You can go to fleshlight.com or you can go to Joe rogan.net which is my website.
And,
um,
you can get like 15% off so you can be fucking this shit code.
Rogan.
Yeah,
there's a coupon code.
It's Rogan.
It says it on the thing.
And then also,
um,
I'm in Ann Arbor,
Michigan.
This,
um,
Friday night,
two shows,
the 10 30 show is already sold out.
Eight 30 shows almost sold out.
So if you want to know those people right now,
there's thinking about going,
you've got to dive on that shit.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm in Denver,
I this weekend at the Denver comedy works.
Check it at Denver comedy works,
one of the best fucking clubs in the country.
And one of the reasons why I moved to Colorado because I knew that called was
there.
They have a real comedy community there.
It's one of the reasons why I decided to move there.
But then some mountain lions and baby's gotten my way.
Oh No.
All good things,
man.
You know,
except the dog that needs,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I don't mean to keep doing,
sorry.
I have a show at the Hollywood forever cemetery tomorrow.
Please go to that.
Comedy is dead.info.
Hollywood forever cemetery.
Yeah,
because these are amazing.
Do these comedy shows in a cemetery shows in a cemetery.
Explained to me what the fuck that is.
It's in a masonic lodge in a cemetery.
It cleaves the Pentagram hanging from the ceiling.
There's a huge,
how have I not done?
The shots were always on the road when you're doing it again tomorrow.
Can I do it?
Yeah.
Don,
summer night done son tomorrow night son.
Where's it at?
It's at the Hollywood forever cemetery.
Uh,
go to comedy.
He's dead dad,
NFL.
It's all the information's right there.
Duncan Trussell you one of my favorite people on the planet.
Thank you very much.
Doing the podcast.
You're a fascinating motherfucker and you always interesting,
right?
It's one of my all time favorite podcast guests.
Holla at your boy Brian Red Band on Twitter.
Red Ba.
Check out my new ice tea video.
That ice tea actually retweeted.
Really?
And it makes fun of his wife and uh,
I can't believe we actually retweeted.
Really?
He must have a good sense of,
he does.
He's like,
he's like alcoholic.
Interesting
Dude.
I hope he doesn't smack you.
It doesn't pimp slap you when he sees you.
She might,
she might pimps,
loud baby bowl.
Youtube it.
She's got a big Ole ass,
Huh?
Yes.
What so was this model we did for all the commercial?
Oh yeah.
I saw the Freddy Lockhart and girl and he was within the model.
Yeah.
My uh,
um,
so that's it folks at Arbor comedy showcase with Thompson Gora just Friday
nights.
Um,
and then of course there's a UFC and Detroit hollow.
I'm looking forward to seeing Detroit.
I feel like I'm going to Rome.
I feel like I'm going to the fucking apocalypse.
I feel like I'm going to go into the land of 33% unemployment rate.
Fucking houses there.
Bear problems right now in Detroit.
Yeah,
I heard of that.
The errors are moving back into the city row.
That's,
that's how abandoned shit is getting fascinating as our society moves towards
2012.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Love you bitches.
And uh,
we'll probably going to do another one this week.
We go away on Thursday,
but I'm,
I might do one tomorrow.
How legible.
See you later.
I'm
doing this
right
girl,
talk.com and download this Google search fees.
Just girl talk
all day for this.